hallo zusammen willkommen zu ZDF heute
live schön dass ihr dabei seid
Deutschland bekommt eine neue Partei
Sarah Wagenknecht wird jetzt gleich das
Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht vorstellen
nach eigenen Angaben soll die Partei für
Vernunft und Gerechtigkeit stehen ja was
ist davon zu erwarten wie stehen die
Chancen dass sich dieses Bündnis in der
Parteienlandschaft etabliert und welche
Auswirkungen wird das haben darüber
wollen wir gleich reden aber jetzt gehen
wir erstmal nach Berlin zur
Pressekonferenz bis
gleich auf ihre Plätze begeben damit wir
dann pünktlich starten
können
ja guten Tag liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen herzlich willkommen in der
Bundespressekonferenz herzlich
willkommen auch unseren Gästen zu meiner
Rechten und zu meiner Linken es geht
heute um die Gründung einer neuen Partei
wie was wie sie heißt und wie die
weiteren
Entwicklung sind werden wir alles gleich
hören dr Sarah Wagenknecht sitzt neben
mir amiraed Ali und Christian le sind
alle drei Mitglieder des Bundestages auf
der anderen Seite herzlich willkommen
Professor Shervin hakschen Fabio demasi
ehemaliges Mitglied des Bundestages und
Thomas Geisel der Oberbürgermeister von
Düsseldorf war und sie sind
Hochschullehrer das habe ich nicht noch
nicht erwähnt wir fangen gleich an Frau
Dr Wagenknecht hat das Wort ja sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren heute Vormittag
haben wir die parteiündnis SAR
Wagenknecht Vernunft und Gerechtigkeit
kurz BSW
gegründet anwesend waren 44
Gründungsmitglieder ein Teil davon war
früher Mitglied der LINKEN ein Teil war
Mitglied einer anderen demokratischen
Partei und es waren auch einige anwesend
die sich bisher noch nie parteipolitisch
engagiert haben dabei waren
Gewerkschafter und Unternehmer Ärzte und
Sozialarbeiter Professoren Abgeordnete
und
Theologen programmatisch haben wir Ihnen
heute nicht so viel Überraschendes
anzubieten dass Partei Programm der
neuen Partei das erste Parteiprogramm
orientiert sich stark am
gründungsaufruf des vereinsbündnis sarer
Wagenknecht wir werden jetzt in einem
längeren Prozess voraussichtlich bis zur
Bundestagswahl ein detaillierteres
Parteiprogramm erarbeiten und wir werden
dafür expertenrte gründen und auch
externen Sachverstand einbeziehen denn
anders als andere Parteien wollen wir
tatsächlich die Programmatik gemeinsam
mit denen entwickeln die von den
Problemen im Land in ihrem Alltag
betroffen sind und die oft besser als
hauptamtliche Politiker wissen welche
Veränderungen ihnen wirklich helfen
würden wir haben heute einen ersten
Parteivorstand gewählt Details wird
gleich Amira Mohammed Ali vorstellen wir
sind mit diesem Vorstand übrigens die
einzige bundesdeutsche Partei mit gleich
zwei Quereinsteigern zwei erfolgreichen
Persönlichkeiten aus der Wirtschaft im
engsten Führungskreis wir haben außerdem
eine Satzung beschlossen die unserem
Anliegen recht trägt kontrolliert und
langsam zu wachsen was die
Mitgliedschaft angeht wer uns sofort
unterstützen möchte den bitten wir auf
unserer Webseite sich als Förderer oder
Unterstützer anzumelden Förderer und
Unterstützer kann jeder sofort werden
und wenn sich viele Menschen für diesen
Weg entscheiden würde uns das sehr
helfen die Europawahl wird die erste
Wahl sein zu der das BSW antritt danach
folgen drei Wahlen in Ostdeutschland und
wir sind zuversichtlich bei allen drei
Wahlen mit kompetenten Landeslisten
antreten zu können gerade in Bezug auf
die Ostdeutschen Landtagswahlen wird ja
derzeit oft davon geredet dass die
Demokratie in Deutschland gefährdet wäre
es ist unseres aachtens oder wäre
unseres Erachtens hilfreich wenn in
dieser Debatte nicht immer wieder
Ursache und Wirkung verwechselt würden
denn die Demokratie in unserem Land wird
in erster Linie gefährdet durch eine
Politik von der sich immer mehr Menschen
im Stich gelassen oder aber vor den Kopf
gestoßen fühlen hier direkt vor der Tür
protestieren heute und auch im ganzen
Land die Landwirte weil sie zurecht
nicht einsehen dass sie für die
Unfähigkeit der Ampel einen soliden
Haushalt aufzustellen am Ende bezahlen
sollen so wie ihnen geht es ganz vielen
Menschen hier im Land auch wenn viele
ihren Groll derzeit noch nicht auf die
Straße tragen sie erleben eine Regierung
die keinen Plan hat außer ihnen das
ohnehin knapper gewordene Geld aus der
Tasche zu ziehen sie erleben einen
Bundeskanzler der sprachlos wirkt selbst
wenn er lange Reden hält und sie erleben
eine Opposition die zu großen Teilen
tatsächlich auch die Politik der
Regierung mitträgt und dann wundert man
sich über Wut Protest und
denkzettelwahlen und Politiker
beschweren sich über ein Volk dass es
irgendwann einfach satt hat so von ihnen
behandelt zu werden wir haben die neue
Partei gegründet damit diese falsche
Politik damit die Unfähigkeit und
Arroganz hier im Berliner
Regierungsbezirk die unsere landpaltet
unsere Zukunft verspielt und unsere
Demokratie gefährdet damit das
überwunden werden
kann vielen Dank Frau Dr WN nicht es
geht weiter mit Frau mohmed Ali ja meine
Damen und Herren in der Tat heute haben
wir es geschafft die neue politische
Kraft aus der Taufe zu heben die unser
Land so dringend braucht unser erster
Parteivorstand besteht aus dar
Wagenknecht und mir als
Parteivorsitzende Christian lei als dem
Generalsekretär Lukas schön dem
Geschäftsführer reif suikat dem
Schatzmeister und Professor Shervin
Haken dem stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden
in den vergangenen Wochen sind viele
Menschen auf uns zugekommen die bisher
nicht in der Politik waren aber die sich
jetzt politisch engagieren wollen weil
sie mit uns gemeinsam unser Land wieder
nach vorne bringen möchten und einer von
ihnen ist Professor Shervin hakin wir
freuen uns wirklich sehr dar über dass
er bereit ist unsere Partei zu
unterstützen seine jahrelange
Führungserfahrung in einem
Industriekonzern und seine herausradende
Kompetenz im Projektmanagement
anspruchsvoller Vorhaben wird sehr sehr
hilfreich für uns sein wir wissen es
geht um viel und wir sind bereit dafür
Danke Schön vielen Dank und das Wort
haben sie gleich bittesch schön Herr
Professor Hako ja vielen Dank ich darf
Sie auch herzlich begrüßen mein Name ist
scherwiin hakschen und ich war bis zum
heutigen Tag kein Politiker im Rahmen
der heutigen Gründungsversammlung wurde
ich zum stellvertretenden
Parteivorsitzenden gewählt zu meiner
Person bin 48 Jahre alt in Teran geboren
und lebe seit meinem zehnten Lebensjahr
in Deutschland als Quereinsteiger bringe
ich 25 Jahre Berufserfahrung mit zu
meinen aus der Wirtschaft durch
Führungsaufgaben in einem
internationalen Baukonzern und Aufbau
eines eigenen Unternehmens zum anderen
aus der Wissenschaft durch die Arbeit
als
Universitätsprofessor W fr tise hat
einmal gesagt die Demokratie ist unser
wertvollstes Gut sie zu erhalten ist
Aufgabe und Verpflichtung zugleich das
ist der Grund warum ich heute hier bin
schauen wir uns die Wahlbeteiligung die
Umfragen an ist es absehbar dass bei der
nächsten Bundestagswahl weniger als 50%
der Wahlberechtigten ihre Stimme für
eine der sogenannten demokratischen
Parteien der Mitte abgeben werden die
Mehrheit hat das Vertrauen in diese
etablierten Parteien
verloren auch das Vertrauen in die
Medien nimmt leider immer mehr ab für
mich sind das alarmierende Entwicklungen
die eine ernsthafte Bedrohung für den
Fortbestand unserer Demokratie
darstellen und auch ich habe in den
vergangenen Jahren Vertrauen verloren es
ist aber keine abstrakte Enttäuschung
sondern die Tatsache dass konkrete
politische Ziele nicht mehr glaubwürdig
vertreten werden möchte gern einige
Punkte nennen die mich aufgrund meiner
eigenen Biographie sehr bewegen Beispiel
Außenpolitik als jemand der Erinnerung
daran hat als Kind in einem Land groß zu
werden ind dem es in einen Krieg gab bin
ich erschüttert dass unsere außen und
Sicherheitspolitik immer mehr darauf
ausgerichtet wird dass unser Land dass
Deutschland immer mehr an militärischen
Einsätzen beteiligt ist statt durch
Diplomatie und Entspannungspolitik
unseren Einfluss in der Welt für Frieden
geltend zu machen gerade mit unserer
Geschichte haben wir eine große
Verantwortung Beispiel Bildungspolitik
als meine Eltern nach Deutschland kamen
hier von vorne anfingen lebten wir viele
Jahre von
Sozialhilfe später machte ich die sehr
prägende Erfahrung dass sozialer
Aufstieg durch Integration und durch
Bildung möglich
ist heute haben wir es nicht nur mit
einem Versagen in der
Integrationspolitik zu tun sondern auch
mit einem maroden Bildungssystem das
soziale Ungerechtigkeit manifestiert und
zudem den fachkräftte Mangel
beschleunigt Beispiel Wirtschafts und
Arbeitsmarktpolitik ich WE eene
Erfahrung dass gute Rahmenbedingungen
für unsere Industrie für den Mittelstand
für die vielen selbständigen aber auch
fair Löhne und sichere Arbeitsplätze
zwei Seiten derselben Medaille sind
viele Unternehmer sind sich der
Verantwortung für ihre Arbeitnehmer sehr
bewusst im Gegensatz zu anonym geführten
Großkonzernen oder globalen
Finanzinvestoren es ist kein Widerspruch
sich für die Interessen der vielen
fleißigen Menschen in unserem Land und
für gute wirtschaftliche
Rahmenbedingungen
einzusetzen die meisten Menschen wollen
doch einfach nur dass ihre Regierung
nicht irgendwelche Ideologien verfolgt
sondern schlicht eine rationale Politik
macht die ihre Lebensbedingungen
verbessert und dass es in unserem Land
wieder gerecht
zugeht ich weiß dass es viele Menschen
gibt die gerade deswegen ihre Hoffnungen
in unser Bündnis
setzen als Bauingenieur und Unternehmer
ist mir der Aufbau von neuem nicht fremd
ich freue mich da daher sehr dass ich
meine Erfahrung an dieser Stelle
einbringen darf um zu
unterstützen und ich möchte zu einer
politischen Kultur beitragen in der
Menschen sich gerne in der Demokratie
engagieren meine Damen und Herren sie
können sich vorstellen dass der heutige
Schritt für mich keine einfache
Entscheidung war ich bin aber zutiefst
davon überzeugt dass wir in Deutschland
eine neue Kraft brauchen die den
Menschen Zuversicht gibt dass Politik
wieder ihre Interessen vertritt und
zugleich die Demokratie stärkt und ich
bin auch davon überzeugt dass die neue
Partei mit ihrer programmatischen
Ausrichtung erfolgreich sein wird da
habe ich mich entschieden nicht mehr an
der Seitenlinie zu stehen sondern mich
auf den Platz zu begeben vielen dank
vielen Dank und Herr Leier hat das Wort
ja sehr geehrte Damen und Herren in
einer Zeit in der die Regierung nicht in
der Lage ist das Land gerecht durch die
Krisen zu führen in Zeiten der Spaltung
in denen die Gesellschaft politisch an
sich selbst verzweifelt soll unsere
Gründung ein Zeichen der Hoffnung sein
wir werden am 27.1 unseren ersten
Parteitag in Berlin abhalten dort wird
auch unsere Europaliste gewählt werden
und unseren Vorschlag für die beiden
spitzenkandidaturen möchte ich Ihnen
heute vorstellen während draußen die
Bauern gegen eine ungerechte und
undurchdachte Finanzpolitik protestieren
setzen wir mit Fabio demasi einen über
die Parteigrenzen hinweg respektierten
Wirtschafts und Finanzpolitiker der bei
der Aufklärung von finanzskandalen den
Bundeskanzler vor sich hertrieb während
in der Bundes und in der Europapolitik
unkluge politische Entscheidungen
getroffen werden die von den Kommunen
ausgebadet werden müssen schlagen wir
einen Mann der Praxis vor Thomas Geisel
war lange Oberbürgermeister der
Landeshauptstadt Düsseldorf und wird
seinen Sachverstand und seine Erfahrung
in den Wahlkampf
einbringen dank dann geht's mit Herr
demasi
weiter sehr verhrte Damen und Herren
meine politische Laufbahn begann vor 10
Jahren im EU-Parlament für mich hat das
ganze von daher etwas von zurück in die
Zukunft bis kürzlich habe ich mich
heftig gegen ein neues politisches
Mandat gesträubt es gab aber mehrere
Schuldige für meinen Sinneswandel
erstens die Ampelkoalition die mit ihrer
desaströsen Politik die Erntehelfer der
AFD in diesem Land sind zweitens die
beharlichkeit von SAR Wagenknecht
Christian Leier und vielen Menschen die
mich an meine eigene politische
Verantwortung in diesen Zeiten erinnert
haben und drittens spannende Mitstreiter
darunter Thomas Geißel und weitere
Überraschungen die Sie in den nächsten
Wochen verfolgen können der Kanzler an
der Spitze der größten Volkswirtschaft
Europas hat nicht nur Erinnerungslücken
bei kumex sondern auch keinen Plan für
die Zukunft in Hamburg versprach er ein
elbtauer und lobte ren Benko über den
grünen Klee heraus kam eine Bauruine in
Deutschland versprach er ein
Wirtschaftswunder und wir stecken in der
Rezession die SPD steht in Sachsen noch
bei 3%
die AFD könnte dort die absolute
Mehrheit der Sitze erringen früher hätte
ein Bundeskanzler bei einer solchen
Performance ein Job als
Frühstücksdirektor angeboten bekommen
wir sind innerhalb der EU eines der
Schlusslichter bei der öffentlichen
investitionsquotte die Ampel hat sich
entschieden trotz ukrainekrieg und
energiepreisschock damals zur
Schuldenbremse zurückzukehren statt sich
ehrlich zu machen und damit eine
Verfassungs und Haushaltskrise ausgelöst
der Bauernaufstand zeigt wie groß der
Druck im Kessel in Deutschland ist wir
steigen ab bei der Infrastruktur wie der
Bahn so wie der les und Mathe Kompetenz
unserer Kinder die bildungsungleichheit
hat sich dramatisch verschärft während
der coronakrise wir haben eine
Wohnungskrise die die Mieten treibt und
die Reallöhne auffrisst außer Italien
ist in keinem anderen G7 Staat sind die
Reallöhne so stark gesunken seit der
coronakrise wie in Deutschland nun
wurden die Mehrwertsteuern wieder
angehoben die die Preise treiben werden
und gehen mit schmalen Kreuz mit
schmalen Schultern das kreuzbrechen eine
Studie unter anderem der schwedischen
Zentralbank kam zum Ergebnis dass eine
solche Politik rechte Parteien in Europa
stärkt mit jeder Woche in der diese
Regierung Deutschland führt verliert
unser Land und Europa auf Jahre hinaus
die Zukunft wir hatten bereits vor der
Zeitenwende ein Verteidigungsetat der
der Atommacht Frankreichs entsprach aber
in einem schwarzen Loch versierte Ursula
von derlein wurde damals für ihren
Berater und beschaffungsfilz auch noch
zur eu-kommissionspräsidentin befördert
dies ist ein Symbol für den Verfall
politischer Verantwortung weniger ist
mehr ich möchte ein Europa dass sein Job
macht und sich auf die Dinge
konzentriert wo es einen Unterschied für
die Menschen machen kann dies betrifft
etwa die minimumbesteuerung
internationaler Konzerne um unsen
Mittelstand zu schützen die Abschöpfung
von übergewinnen im Energiesektor die
Unterbindung von lohndampping im
Binnenmarkt und den schutzortsüblicher
Tariflöhne damit Zustände W uns
Schlachthöfen nicht um sich greifen die
Reform des beihil und Vergaberechts für
eine aktive Industriepolitik und eine
Reform der europäischen Schuldenbremsen
um Investitionen zu ermöglichen die
Förderung einer digitalen europäischen
Infrastruktur um unsere Abhängigkeit von
bigtech Konzern aus den USA zu
verringern und eine Agrarpolitik die die
Landwirte nicht internationalen
getreidebörsen oder den aldibrüdern
ausliefert wir brauchen auch
diplomatische Initiativen im
ukrainekonflikt und angesichts der
Tragödie im Gaza meine Damen und Herren
die teilweise heftigen Reaktionen auf
meine Kandidatur haben mir gezeigt die
politischen Mitbewerber sind nervös und
dazu sollten Sie auch einen Grund haben
vielen dank vielen Dank herasi Herr
Geisel hat das Wort meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren ich bin ja bereits
vorgestellt worden Thomas Geißel ich war
6 Jahre lang Oberbürgermeister von
Düsseldorf davor war ich 15 Jahre lang
in leitenden Funktionen in der
Energiewirtschaft tätig ich war 40 Jahre
lang Mitglied der SPD heute habe ich
mich im Bündnis Sara Wagenknecht
Vernunft und Gerechtigkeit angeschlossen
maßgeblich dafür waren vor allem drei
Gründe erstens ich kann mich nicht
erinnern dass unser Land sich jemals in
einem so schlechten Zustand bef befunden
hat wie heute aus dem Modell Deutschland
der eher Helmut Schmidt ist ein
Sanierungsfall geworden und die Probleme
sind ganz überwiegend hausgemacht unsere
Verkehrsinfrastruktur ist in einem
beklagenswerten Zustand der Ausbau der
Stromnetze und damit die Energiewende
kommt nicht voran und bei der
Digitalisierung ist Deutschland
mittlerweile abgehängt immer mehr
Bürokratie lähmt unternehmerische
Initiative und was vielleicht noch
schlimmer ist sinnlose Verbote und
Symbolpolitik Gefährten den
Industriestandort bestes Beispiel ist
vielleicht das Verbot von
verbrennermotoren ab dem Jahr 2035 damit
werden nicht nur 100ertausende von
qualifizierten Arbeitsplätzen in
Deutschland auf Spiel gesetzt damit wird
der Industrie auch jeder Anreiz genommen
sparsamere Motoren zu entwickeln und
letztlich wird damit auch dem
Klimaschutz ein Bärendienst
erwiesen zweitens Voraussetzung für
einen funktionierenden Sozialstaat ist
der soziale Zusammenhalt und der ist in
Deutschland zunehmend gefährdet die
Schere zwischen Arm und Reich geht immer
weiter auf wer heute reich geboren wird
bleibt in der Regel reich und wer arm
geboren wird hat immer weniger die
Chance durch flei und Anstrengung nach
oben zu kommen aus einer
Leistungsgesellschaft troht eine
besitzstandsgesellschaft zu werden wer
sich private Bildung Kliniken und
Sicherheitsdienst leisten kann entzieht
sich immer mehr der gesellschaftlichen
Solidarität und nach unten entwickeln
sich
Parallelgesellschaften namentlich in
migrantischen milies die durch
unkontrollierte Zuwanderung wachsen und
immer schwieriger zu integrieren sind
doch statt massiv in ein Bildungssystem
zu investieren des soziale Gerechtigkeit
des Chancengleichheit verwirklicht
verstecken wir uns hinter
Identitätspolitik und führen
genderdebatten und für eine
Steuerpolitik die den gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenhalt stärkt die Leistung
honoriert und soziale Durchlässigkeit
fördert fehlt der Mut vielleicht auch
die Fantasie drittens Deutschland unter
sozialer und unter sozialdemokratischer
Führung stand immer für eine Politik des
Friedens der Entspannung und der
Stabilität in internationalen
Beziehungen ich darf erinnern Willi
Brand hat hierfür 1971 den
Friedensnobelpreis erhalten und Gerhard
Schröder gemeinsam mit shakchirak hat
uns im Jahr 2001 vor einer Teilnahme am
Irakkrieg bewahrt heute ist Deutschland
hauptwaffenlieferant der Ukraine in
einem Krieg der nicht gewonnen werden
kann die gegenwärtige Bundesregierung
möchte unser Land kriegstüchtig machen
redet einem neuen Kalten Krieg das Wort
und beteiligt sich an Wirtschafts gegen
Russland die dem eigenen Land definitiv
mehr Schaden als Russland es ist leider
so Sozialdemokraten die sie in der
Tradition von Willi Brand und Helmut
Schmidt sehen sind in der SPD heimatlos
geworden aber was noch schlimmer ist
immer mehr Menschen scheinen die
Hoffnung aufgegeben zu haben dass
Politik noch irgendetwas Gutes bewirken
kann sie wenden sich ab begegnen der
Politik mit Wut und Sarkasmus und wählen
Protest oder gar nicht das Bündnis Sara
Wagenknecht Vernunft und Gerechtigkeit
stellt sich diesem Trend entgegen diese
Partei steht für eine Politik für eine
Wirtschaftspolitik mit Sachverstand äh
Sachverstand Vernunft und Augenmaß sie
steht für eine Politik die soziale
Durchlässigkeit und gesellschaftliche
Dynamik fördert individuelle Leistung
honoriert und den sozialen Zusammenhalt
wiederherstellt und sie steht für eine
Außenpolitik die im deutschen und
europäischen Interesse auf Frieden
entspannt und Stabilität sitzt wir sind
eine Partei die nicht beschönigt sondern
die Tatsachen so wie Sie sind zur
Kenntnis nimmt eine Partei die nicht in
ihrer eigenen Blase verhartt sondern
Impulse von außen aufnimmt und vor allem
die nicht resentiments bedient sondern
nach vernünftigen Lösungen strebt
deshalb bin ich dabei vielen Dank Herr
Geisel wir kommen jetzt zu fragen ich
sage nur mal an ich habe ja schon ein
gutes halbes ein gutes dutzen mehr als
ein dutzen Fragen auf meinem Zettel
stehen die sich ergeben hat ich kann
nicht mehr sicherstellen dass ich hier
alles in der Reihenfolge ja Moment bitte
dass hier in der Reihenfolge der
Meldungen vorgehe ich werde das hier ein
bisschen geographisch machen möchte
daran erinnern dass wir eine Frage und
höchstens aber nicht zwingend eine
Nachfrage haben damit alle noch dran
kommen je weniger Nachfragen wir haben
desto mehr kommen dran ganz klar und ich
bitte noch den Adressaten zu nennen und
bei ihnen geht es bitte
los ich habe eine Frage an Herrn Geisel
Herr Geisel ihr stellvertretender
Parteivorsitzende hat eben gesagt
wirlich Glaubwürdigkeit die Politik und
die Demokratie ist die passt dazu dass
sie noch vor kurzem vor vier Wochen etwa
als sie 40jähriges parteijubiläum in der
SPD hatten gesagt haben dass sie für
immer Sozialdemokrat bleiben wollten und
heute als spenkandidat einer anderen
Partei nach Brüssel gehen wollen man
könnte den Andruck be kommen es liegt
daran dass es ein sehr ja lukratives
Mandat ist
und mit der neuen Partei zusammenhängt
also wie erklären diesen Sinneswandel
das ist überhaupt kein Sinneswandel ich
habe diesen Satz damals bei meiner
Ehrung sehr bewusst so gesagt wer meine
gesamte Rede bei diesem Anlass gehört
hat wird gemerkt haben dass ich schon
damals sehr deutlich gemacht haben habe
dass Sozialdemokraten wie gesagt die
sozialisiert wurden in der Zeit von
Willi Brand und Helmut Schmidt
mittlerweile heimatlos in der SPD
geworden sind ich habe nicht gesagt ich
werde mein Leben lang Mitglied der SPD
bleiben ich werde mein Leben lang bei
sozialdemokratischen Grundsätzen treu
bleiben und die sehe ich in diesem in
dieser neuen Partei besser aufgehoben
als in der
SPD dann z ganz Kur nach wann kam denn
das Angebot mit dieser Partei zu werden
ich bin mit Sarah Wagenknecht seit
langer Zeit im Gespräch wir kennen uns
genau genommen eigentlich seit über 30
Jahren wir sind etwas enger im Kontakt
seit ich wir haben bei uns zu Hause eine
Einrichtung der nennt sich politischeer
Salon da hatte ich Sarah wagencht mal
eingeladen seither sind wir regelmäßig
im Kontakt und der engere Kontakt auch
das Thema Mitglied dieser neuen Partei
zu werden die es in den letzten zwei
Monaten in vielen Gesprächen gewachsen
so dann geht's dahinter
weiter un nicht deshalb
weil genug ist da stellt sich die Frage
ist Selbstverständis der BSW eine linke
Partei zu sein und wie spielt sich das
in den
in ja also viele Menschen können ja
einfach mit diesen Labels Links oder
auch rechts nicht mehr viel anfangen und
das ist ein Kernproblem wenn man das man
wenn man eine linke Identität so
definiert dass dafür essentiell ist sich
für soziale Gerechtigkeit einsetz
zuetzen eine Stimme auch derer zu sein
die in unserer Gesellschaft immer unter
die Räder kommen die seit Jahren von der
Politik vergessen wurden in dem Sinne
natürlich treten wir dieses Erbe an und
wollen es auch ausdrücklich aber für
viele Menschen ist links ja heutzutage
mit ganz anderen Debatten besetzt da
geht es um genderfagen da geht es um
Lifestyle Fragen und davon fühlen sie
sich nicht mehr vertreten und deswegen
werden wir diese Labels nicht für uns
benutzen sie werden ihr teril finden wie
wir wie sie uns einordnen aber diese
Tradition die eine linke Tradition
natürlich immer gewesen ist soziale
Gerechtigkeit weniger Ungleichheit ein
gesellschaftlicher Zusammenhalt oder
auch das Bestreben nach Frieden nach
Entspannungspolitik meine das ja völlig
absurd dass heutzutage irgendwie
Waffenlieferungen und und und
Rüstungsexporte in Kriegsgebiete als
links gelten das ist ja völlig
aberwitzig immer war das eigentlich eine
linke Position dafür zu werben dass
Konflikte diplomatisch auf dem
Verhandlungsweg gelöst werden und das
wird etwas sein das das haben sie auch
in den eingangsbeiträgen gehört was
unsere Partei ausmachen wird und wo was
wir auch sehr sehr deutlich vertreten n
in seiner Austrittserklärung gesagt
würde sich dafür aussprechen das
individuelle recht Asyl abzuschaffen
gehört das ihrer Sicht zu den Dingen den
linken eigentlich Forderungen die sie
nicht
mehr ich glaube das ist missverstanden
worden es steht sehr deutlich in der
Erklärung wir sind uns da auch völlig
einig dass
selbstverständlich wenn Menschen
politisch verfolgt werden dass sie dann
auch ein Recht auf Schutz haben das
Problem ist dass so wie die Gesetze
heute ausgestaltet sind das zu sehr
langen Verfahren führt und in der Regel
nicht dazu dass Menschen die verfolgt
werden in erster Linie Schutz bekommen
sondern das sehen wir ja an den Zahlen
noch nicht mal 1% derer die die einen
Asylantrag stellen wirklich auch ein
Asylrecht haben und deswegen wollen wir
dass tatsächlich auch nicht nur
diejenigen die teure Schlepper bezahlen
können nach Europa kommen deswegen sind
wir für Asylverfahren an den
Außengrenzen ich habe vor kurzem wieder
ein Schreiben bekommen von jemanden aus
Afghanistan der dort gearbeitet hat für
die deutschen und der völlig im Stich
gelassen sich fühlt und verfolgt wird
und Angst hat und nicht viel Geld hat
und keine Schlepper bezahlen kann kommen
solche Menschen überhaupt nach
Deutschland zurzeit nicht das heißt die
bisherige Asylpolitik ist eindeutig
verfehlt wir haben eine kontrollierte
Migration die Zahlen sind zu hoch da
sind wir uns einig gleichzeitig und das
ist uns allerdings auch ein anliegen
sollte und muss Deutschland mehr dafür
tun dass Menschen in ihrer Heimat auch
wieder Perspektiven haben da geht es um
viele Fragen um eine andere
Wirtschaftspolitik da geht es aber eben
auch z.B wieder um die Frage Konflikte
friedlich zu lösen überall wo kriege
entstehen entsteht Flucht und entsteht
die Notwendigkeit dass Menschen ihre
Heimat verlassen auch das gehört zu
diesem Thema natürlich sehr sehr
zwingend dazu aber die bisherige
Asylpolitik führt eben genau nicht dazu
dass in erster Linie die Menschen Schutz
erhalten die ihn brauchen sondern es ist
ein Selektionsmechanismus man muss
zunächst mal Geld haben man kann dadurch
in die EU kommen und am Ende haben wir
zahlen in Deutschland wo wirklich
Integration versagt und dass das so
nicht weitergehen kann sie können mit
jedem Kommunalpolitiker in Deutschland
sprechen der ihnen das bestätigen wird
hier muss sich dringend etwas verändern
Herr Geisel sie waren ja indirekt
angesprochen wollen ich wollte nur so
sagen wissen Sie ich darf darauf
verweisen ich wäend meiner Amtszeit als
Oberbürgermeister von Düsseldorf ich
glaube es gab kaum eine Stadt wo es eine
so lebhafte Willkommenskultur gab die
ganze Stadtgesellschaft hat sich
beteiligt Flüchtlinge aufzunehmen man
muss nur einfach sagen das individuelle
Grundrecht auf Asyl ist kein geeignetes
Instrument weil es tatsächlich die Tür
öffnet für eine unkontrollierte
Zuwanderung und die bringt und das sage
ich als ehemaliger Kommunalpolitiker die
bringt die Kommunen einfach an ihre
Grenzen es muss gewissermaßen so
gesteuert werden können dass wir
möglichst vielen die Hilfe bedürfen
aufnehmen können aber eben nur an bis
zur Grenze der Integrationsfähigkeit das
ist ein Thema da geht's ja nicht nur um
Unterbringung da geht es um um wirkliche
Integration um Kindergärten um Schulen
um Integration durch Arbeit und wenn sie
mit Kommunalpolitikern sprechen alle
werden Ihnen sagen wir sind mittlerweile
am Limit es ist eine Grenze erreicht bei
allem besten Willen und ich glaube
gerade unter meiner Führung in
Düsseldorf war der Wille sehr sehr gut
aber wir müssen die Tatsachen zur
Kenntnis nehmen und von daher glaube ich
ist es in der Tat richtig hier wie Sarah
Wagen nicht sagt dass man das Verfahren
neu gestaltet so wie es gegenwerärtig
läuft ist es glaube ich
wirklich bringt es die Kommunen jenseits
der Grenze wissen Sie die Kanzlerin hat
damals gesagt wir schaffen das wer hat's
denn geschafft es waren die Kommunen das
war ja nicht die Bundespolitik sondern
es wurde im sie die Arbeit wurde abge
abge gewissermaßen abgelagert auf die
Kommunen die haben das Menschenmögliche
getan aber irgendwann sind Grenzen
erreicht jetzt schaffen wir die nächste
Frage die geht gleich daneben weiter die
nächste Frau
dudin haben bereits die Bauern
angesprochen hab die Verbrennermotor
angesprochen Ideen für eine klimapolik
und ich wollte das ein halten ist das
Wort relevant für okay ja natürlich ist
der Klimawandel eine ernste
Herausforderung das steht ja auch in
unserem ersten Parteiprogramm dass wir
natürlich Initiativen für sinnvoll
halten aber dass das auch mit
Ehrlichkeit geschehen muss und es nützt
ja nicht wenn wir uns eine wünscht ihr
was Welt vorstellen erstens kann
Deutschland das alleine nicht bewältigen
also wir haben ja alle gesehen bei der
letzten Klimakonferenz dass das global
sehr unterschiedlich diskutiert wird und
zweitens sollten wir in Deutschland die
Schritte gehen die sinnvoll sind also
nehmen wir ein Beispiel das W das
heißungsgesetz ist nicht sinnvoll und
ich glaube dass es wirklich völlig
aberwitzig ist dass die Koalition die
also immer noch ihren Haushalt ja nicht
irgendwie auf die Reihe gebracht hat
also es ist ja immer noch nicht klar wie
jetzt die Löcher gestopft werden
ausgerechn an diesem sinnlosen
heizungsgesetz festhält während
gleichzeitig ein anderer Weg auch bei
der Wärme deutlich CO2 zu reduzieren
nicht mit entsprechenden Unterstützungen
gegang wird nämlich die kommunale
wärmeplanung also alle die sich etwas
auskennen mit denen ich gesprochen habe
sagen mir übrigens auch
Kommunalpolitiker dass der Ausbau der
Fernwärme und eine eine Umgestaltung der
Fernwärme in Richtung klimaneutraler
Ressourcen ein sehr viel realistischerer
Weg wäre als dass jetzt in lauter alte
Häuser Wärmepumpen eingebaut werden also
erstens ruiniert das viele Menschen weil
sie die Kosten nicht stemmen können und
zweitens kann man ältere Häuser einfach
mit einer Wärmepumpe nicht warm bekommen
andere Länder zeigen bei der Fernwärme
gibt es viele neue Verfahren um aus
Abwasserwärme zu entnehmen also es gibt
da schon sehr viel Möglichkeiten
realistisch ist es allerdings so dass
die Kommunen in Deutschland kein Geld
haben also die meisten Kommunen nicht
und ich habe mit Bürgermeistern
gesprochen sogar von wohlhabenden
Kommunen die mir gesagt haben na ja also
da sind unsere Limits erschöpft da gibt
es keine Unterstützung stattdessen wird
das Geld verpulvert zum Einbau von
werbepumpen also das eine Beispiel soll
nur zeigen es geht nicht darum keine
klimapol zu machen aber es geht darum
eine Klimapolitik zu machen bei der
jeder eingesetzte Euro den möglichst
hohen Effekt hat in Deutschland und
nicht irgendeine Ideologie nachzulaufen
oder irgendwelche hobbyprojekte wo
vielleicht
Staatssekretäre auch persönlich mit
profitieren da zu bedienen und bei der
Verkehrspolitik ist es ähnlich also es
wird jetzt ja ja es wird die Maut erhöht
bei den bei den LKWs sogar beträchtlich
das wird am Ende auf die Kommunen auf
die Konsumenten übergelegt übergetragen
das hei wird noch mal zu
Preissteigerungen führen weil man
angeblich damit
klimaneutralen Güterverkehr bevorzugen
will ist aber völlig absurd also das das
E-Auto ist für den lkwverkehr nicht
sinnvoll das brennstoffauto ist noch
nicht wirklich marktfähig was allerdings
sinnvoll wäre wäre natürlich mehr Güter
auf die Schiene zu verlagern aber die
staatseigene Bahn hat in den letzten
Jahren massiv ihre Kapazitäten zum
Gütertransport abgebaut das heißt das
zeigt auch wieder eine völlig
irrationale Politik also das ist das was
wir auch meinen Rückkehr der Vernunft in
die Politik man macht eine Maut man
belastet die LKWs es gibt aber
eigentlich gar keine Alternative also
erhöht man nur die Preise sinnvoll wäre
Kapazitäten bei der Bahn zu erhöhen
viele Unternehmen würden ja gerne ihre
Güter auf der Schiene transportieren es
gibt ja viel mehr Nachfrage als Angebot
also das wäre ein Weg hier etwas zu tun
und so gibt es viele Bereiche
Verbrennermotor hat Thomas Geisel
angesprochen natürlich wäre es wenn man
auch die globale Sicht hat viel
sinnvoller gewesen wen den Autokonzernen
Anreize oder auch entsprechenden Druck
zu geben verbrauchsärmere Verbrenner zu
produzieren das ist das knohow was wir
hier haben da sind wir weltweit führend
im Verbrennermotor stattdessen verbietet
man ihn macht auch noch sozusagen solche
Durchschnittswerte für die gesamtflotte
S dass sie einerseits beim Verbrenner
jetzt eben weiterhin ihre SUVs
produzieren wenn sie dann entsprechende
E-Mobilität auch in den Markt bringen am
Ende wird es wenn das wirklich dabei
bleibt beim verbrennerverbot
wahrscheinlich dazu führen dass sehr
sehr viele gutbezahlte Arbeitsplätze
hier wegfallen werden weil bei dem
batterieauto sind wir nicht
weltmarktführend es wird aber weltweit
nach wie vor sehr viele Verbrenner auf
der Straße geben also egal wie die EU
sich verhält in allen anderen Teilen der
Welt wird die Zahl wachsen also hätte
man fürs globale Klima mehr erreicht
wenn man hier tatsächlich
verbrauchsärmere Modelle entwickelt
hätte das hätte ein Exportschlager
werden können also das sind nur drei
Beispiele es gibt noch viel mehr ich
will aber jetzt auch nicht zu lange
reden was eine sinnvolle Klimapolitik
von einer Ideologie getriebenen
unvernünftigen Klimapolitik
unterscheidet und wir stehen für eine
Klimapolitik die wirklich einerseits
sich an dem Machbaren orientiert
wirklich etwas erreicht aber eben im
Bereich dessen was tatsächlich auch den
heutigen Technologien und dem
technologisch möglichen
entspricht dann geht es weiter mit Frau
dudin ich kann all das Mikro nicht sehen
ist das weiß
super eine Frage an Fr vorhin gesagt die
Partei sollle kontrolliert und langsam
wachsen was sind denn die
Einschränkungen für eine
Mitgliedschaft also es gibt natürlich
keine formalen Einschränkungen es wird
aber so sein dass wir Mitglieder
kennenlernen also dass man sich vorerst
also jetzt nicht ich persönlich nicht
jedes Mitglied persönlich begrüßen
können aber dass unsere Gliederungen wir
werden ja jetzt in einem ersten Schritt
450 Menschen aufnehmen heute und morgen
dass dann dadurch haben wir sozusagen
schon zwar noch keine gegründeten
Landesverbände aber wir haben in allen
Bundesländern haben wir dann
entsprechende Strukturen und wer sich
dann neu anmeldet dem legen wir nah
erstmal auch als Unterstützer sich zu
betätigen sich einzubringen dann werden
wir die Menschen kennenlernen und dann
werden sie natürlich auch Mitglied
werden können aber sie müssen einfach
und da appelliere ich auch daran dass
ich weiß dass viele Menschen haben mir
auch schon gesagt haben sie möchten gern
Mitglied werden wir müssen natürlich
aufpassen dass wir nicht in die Falle
tappen die junge neue Parteien oft
tappen dass sie eben Menschen auch
aufnehmen manchmal die auch schon durch
fünf Parteien durchgezogen sind die
jetzt nicht so konstruktiv sich
einbringen und wir müssen natürlich
aufpassen völlig klar dass wir nicht
Menschen einsammeln die eine ganz andere
Richtung wollen als wir sie jetzt in
unseren
gründungsdokumenten vorgegeben haben
damit die Parteien nicht sich in eine
Weise entwickelt die gar nicht dem
entspricht warum wir sie heute auf den
Weg gebracht haben und warum so viele
Menschen Hoffnung in diese Partei setzen
und deswegen müssen wir das
ja müssen wir da ein bisschen genauer
hingucken wer wird bei uns wirklich
Mitglied wer wer betätigt sich dort wir
möchten allen die sich ehrlich
einbringen wollen die einen
konstruktiven Beitrag leisten wollen all
die werden perspektivisch natürlich auch
die Chance dazu haben aber erst einmal
ist es für uns wichtig dass Menschen
sich für uns und auch in den Wahlkämpfen
als Unterstützer registrieren das sind
diejenigen die dann wirklich auch mit
uns die Wahlkämpfe führen werden jetzt
im nächsten Jahr oder diejenigen die das
erübrigen können dass sie Förderer der
Partei werden das sind diejenigen die
uns mit regelmäßigen Beiträgen
unterstützen beides hilft uns sehr weil
wir natürlich jetzt in diesem Jahr im
Grunde eine mmut Aufgabe vor uns haben
wir müssen einerseits vier Wahlkämpfe
bestreiten also ein bundesweiten und
drei landeswahlkämpfe und wir müssen
gleichzeitig Parteistrukturen aufbauen
also das ist schon erhe eine ziemliche
schwierig ziemlich schwierige Aufgabe
und damit wir das gut können brauchen
wir vor allem auch viele Unterstützer
viele Förderer und daraus werden dann
natürlich auch perspektivisch Mitglieder
werden W ehemalige AFD Mitgliedschaft
ein
ausschlusskt also ein direkten Wechsel
wird es nicht geben und wie gesagt wir
gucken uns natürlich jeden an der kommt
weil es ist klar wenn man Mitglied
unserer Partei werden möchte dann muss
man schon unsere Programmatik teilen und
wer jetzt aktuell sich in der AFD
engagiert und dort Mitglied ist also bei
den Wählern ist das sicherlich anders
aber wer aktuell der AFD Mitglied ist
der teilt die D dortige Programmatik und
der teilt vor allem auch das was in
Teilen dieser Partei vertreten wird und
das ist sehr sehr weit weg von dem was
wir wollen also soweit glaube ich aus
inhaltlichen Gründen sehe ich das
eigentlich nicht als möglich an Herr
Steiner dann Herr
Jessen sie sind
drüberekommen AöR das nicht so genau
aber der Z Parteien Set klar vor dass
befristete aufnahm auch unzulässig W sie
würden also sagen dass es keine
aufnahmperre im Sinne des Gesetzes
sondern
die dass das immer noch möglich ist zu
werden aber le werden soll nein ist also
ich habe doch gerade gesagt wir nehmen
jetzt erstmal 450 Menschen auf und
selbstverständlich werden wir weiterhin
immer wieder Menschen aufnehmen wir
werden ja Menschen kennenlernen also ich
persönlich kenne einige die jetzt
Meinweg in dem ersten Schub noch nicht
drin sind die ich aber jetzt in den
letzten Wochen kennengelernt habe die
dann aufgenommen werden
selbstverständlich gibt es keinen
aufnahmeschub wir wollen ja auch wachsen
wir wollen ja mehr Mitglieder gewinnen
und wir freuen uns dass es so viel
Interesse gibt also das ist ja was
positives also es wäre ja viel
schlechter wenn jetzt irgendwie wir
werben müssten werde Mitglied und keiner
meldet sich also das wäre ja doch eine
sehr traurige Situation wir haben das
umgekehrte Problem dass sehr viele
Menschen Interesse haben auch jetzt
schon geschrieben haben auch jetzt schon
gesagt haben sie wollen Mitglied werden
und wir werden all diesen Menschen
natürlich wenn Sie unsere Programmatik
teilen wenn sie sich konstruktiv
einbringen genau die Chance dafür geben
aber wir müssen eben gucken dass es
nicht die falschen sind die eine ganz
andere Ideologie haben oder die eben so
wie das bei vielen jungen Parteien ist
doch dann eher die die Strukturen in
Schwierigkeiten bringen da müssen wir
einfach auch eine gewisse Auswahl
treffen und das ist nach dem
Parteiengesetz natürlich zulässig es
gibt immer die Möglichkeit also
Aufnahmeanträge eben zu bewilligen oder
auch nicht ich als
nach
europesag weniger ist
mehr ja das ist relativ einfach wir
haben eine Europäische Union die ja sehr
weit mittlerweile unsere Gesetzgebung
beeinflusst und ich finde das Problem
war bisher in der in der politischen
Debatte über Europa dass wirklich da wo
die Erwartungen sind wo Europa ein
Unterschied machen kann also z.B gegen
steuerdamping von Konzernen Amazon Apple
und Co die dann auch unseren Mittelstand
bedrohen da hat sie nicht geliefert und
gibt's dann immer die Ausrede ja wir
finden keine Einigung ja wir finden
keine Einigung es gibt immer ein
vetopieler Luxemburg oder wen auch immer
es gibt aber auch Dinge die z.B Gruppen
willlliger Staaten machen können und
Herr Scholz z.B hat sich ja gefeiert
bevor er Bundeskanzler wurde dafür dass
er jetzt die internationale
minimumbesteuerung durchgesetzt hätte
die ist löchrig wie ein Schweizer Käse
da hat sich dann schön auch von den
Zeitungen irgendwie auf dem Schnellboot
in Venedig inszenieren lassen ist auch
ganz schön bin ich auch schon gefahren
aber ähm in der Substanz kam da wenig
herum weil er im Prinzip den Steuersatz
dort angesetzt hat wo jetzt schon die
meisten steuoasen sind und da erwarten
sich die Menschen tatsächlich auch mehr
Europa es gibt aber andere Bereiche also
kommunale Selbstverwaltung da möchte ich
nicht dass die Europäische Union überall
eingreift und wir haben in der Eurokrise
gesehen also wenn wir bestimmte
Entscheidungsstrukturen
zentralisieren wurde dann Krisenländern
gesagt ja ihr könnt ja ein bisschen Geld
und Unterstützung haben vorher zwingt
man sie aber in die Krise reinzukürzen
sehen Sie Italien z.B hat ja eine
Ministerpräsidentin aus einer bestimmten
politischen Tradition das ist ja auch
kein Zufall das ist Ergebnis auch einer
Politik gegenüber diesem Land Italien
hat bis zur coronakrise 30 Jahre lang
das wissen die wenigsten
primärüberschüsse im Haushalt gehabt das
heißt sie haben Haushaltsüberschüsse
gehabt jedes Jahr die wurden aber von
den Zinsen auf die Altschulden
aufgefressen und in dem Land wurde nicht
investiert und das hat politische Kosten
das hat ökonomische Kosten das hat
soziale Kosten und hier würde ich mir
z.B wünschen dass EU Mitgliedstaaten
mehr in eigener Verantwortung
entscheiden können damit sie eben nicht
das Gefühl hat die Wählerschaft das
entscheidet jetzt Berlin obwohl sie
nicht Herrn Scholz oder damals Frau
Merkel gewählt haben so und diese
Balance die gilt es zu wahen in Europa
und das meine ich mit weniger als mehr
also muss nicht alles machen aber sie
muss dort liefern wo sie auch wirklich
ein Unterschied machen kann Herr
jeninten ich habe eine Frage an Herr
Geisel sie haben im vergangenen Jahr in
einem läeren Dokument eine Reformagenda
damals noch für die SPD und für
Deutschland
vorgelegt darin offenbaren sie sich als
ein nachhaltiger verfeächter der Agenda
2010 von Gert Schulder und die fordern
dass eine neue Balance des Prinzips
fördern und fordern ähm reaktiviert
werden muss inwiefern sehen Sie diese
beiden Punkte Agenda 2010 und Fördern
und Fordern in dieser neuen für die
neuen Partei besser begründet
als in der die sie verlassen hab nee
also zunächst mal die Partei die ich
verlassen habe die hat ja nun
mittlerweile Gerhard Schröder zu ihrem
Hauptfeind erklärt wenn ich das richtig
sehe also von daher würde mir das da gar
nicht sper fallallen aber wenn Sie das
Thema förder und fordern oder
Sozialpolitik ansprechen ich glaube was
das Thema Sozialstaat angeht das ist
etwas ich habe das ja auch hier in
meinem Eingangsstatement erwähnt was mir
gerade als Sozialdemokrat ausgesprochen
wichtig ist Sozialstaat sitzt soziale
sozialen Zusammenhalt frus was wichtig
ist glaube ich Solidarität ist natürlich
immer auch ein Stück weit ein Geschäft
auf Gegenseitigkeit dass der Staat
selbstverständlich in der Lage sein muss
und alles unternehmen muss um denen zu
helfen die Gegenwert nicht in der Lage
sind aus welchen Gründen auch immer
ihren Beitrag zum Gemeinwesen zu leisten
aber so es der Staat tut kann er
natürlich auch erwarten dass sie diesen
Beitrag leisten ich bin definitiv ein
Gegner eines bedingungslosen
Grundeinkommens und ich halte es für
richtig dass der Staat stark ist
Menschen hilft dass sich aber nicht
gleichzeitig eine wie soll wir sagen ein
Milieu von Kostgängern almosenempfängern
entwickelt sondern wie gesagt ein Geben
und Nehmen stattfinde ich ich kann als
Kommunalpolitiker sagen es gibt
natürlich mittlerweile ein Milieu von
verfestigter Dauer
Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit ist ist eine
große Aufgabe die der Staat leisten muss
diese Menschen wieder heranzuführen
gegenwärtig ist es auch besonders
geboten denn wir leben ja nicht in einer
Zeit von Massenarbeitslosigkeit sondern
in einer Zeit von tendenziell eher
arbeitskräf Mangel und deswegen ist
glaube ich hier die Aufgabe sehr groß
dass man die Menschen ernst nimmt ist
eine Frage des Respektes dann kann man
im Gegensatz im Gegenzug aber auch
erwarten dass sie bereits in ihren
Beitrag leisten was nicht geht sind
Karrieren von ich sag mal Bürgergeld und
Schwarzarbeit das ist das was glaube ich
keine das ist auch keine respektvolle
Sozialpolitik her sie wollten jetzt Herr
Demi würde gerne
ergänzen ich würde gerne ergänzen also
ich habe mich ja im Vorfeld meiner
Kandidatur auch z.B mit Herrn Geisel
getroffen wir erstmal wissen wollten wie
wir miteinander klar kommmen und wo
unsere politischen Punkte lien und klar
ist wir streben an mittelfristig eine
Volkspartei zu sein das heißt wir werden
natürlich auch immer Nuancen und
Debatten haben das völlig normal aber es
gibt überhaupt kein Zweifel darüber habe
ich mich mit her Geisel auch lang lange
ausgetauscht wie wir z.B auf den
jetzigen sozialstat blicken und ich näh
jetzt mal an dem Beispiel von
Arbeitslosenversicherung es ist kennen
ja auch die entsprechenden
programmatischen Dokumente die wir jetzt
auch vorbereiten es ist ganz klar dass
wir sagen wir eigentlich wieder eine
Arbeitslosenversicherung in der die
langjährig Versicherten länger geschützt
sind bevor sie dann überhaupt in dieser
Situation kommen ins Bürgergeld zu gehen
das ist der erste Punkt der zweite Punkt
ist aus der politischen Traditionslinie
aus der ich komme da haben wir immer
gesagt das Problem damals an Harz 4 war
ja dass man den Gewerkschaften das Kreuz
gebrochen hat dadurch dass man gesagt
hat ihr müsst unabhängig davon was ihr
vor gearbeitet habt wie lange ihr
eingezahlt habt
auch Jobs annehmen die die unter Niveau
bezahlt sind und durch die
Zumutbarkeitskriterien ist Druck auf die
Löhne entstanden das ist etwas was wir
auch ganz klar ablehnen der dritte Punkt
ist dass wir
natürlich sagen wir müssen im Bereich
der jüngeren Erwerbstätigen brauchen wir
auch Mitwirkungspflichten und zwar auch
aus derer Fürsorgepflicht damit die eben
nicht in der Depression landen und am
Ende dann tatsächlich auch
Beschäftigungsfähigkeit verlieren das
heißt aber man muss ihn vernünftige
Angebote machen also ich ne immer so
mein ich hatte Malin Hausmeister der hat
immer zu mir gesagt ich Wurstfinger aber
muss in den Schreibmaschinenkurs das
bringt natürlich nichts s man muss eben
auch
Qualifizierungsmöglichkeiten schaffen
das ist ja gerade bei den Jüngeren
häufig das Problem und das ist der
Dreiklang den wir da haben das heißt wir
wollen eben und das ist ja auch
angesprochen jetzt hier mit der
Schwarzarbeit wäre z.B ein ganz
deutlicher Faktor um das zu reduzieren
es gibt's ja tatsächlich dass wir
vernünftige Löhne brauchen damit so
etwas nicht mehr steht und das ist äh
sagen der der der Zentrum unser
politischer Anker und der ist auch ganz
unstrittig zwischen uns beiden haben wir
auch lange drüber gesprochen Nachfrage
noch mal Herrn Geisel in diesem Dokument
der Reformagenda kritisieren sie sehr
heftig Subventionen die in Deutschland
gezahlt werden sie fordern drastischen
Abbau von Subvention jetzt hat ihre neue
Parteiführung sich ausdrücklich an die
Seite der Protestierenden Landwirte
gestellt
derenanforderung ist aber kein Abbau von
Subventionen sondern völliger Erhalt der
Subvention wie passen diese beiden
Position zusammen ich würde mal so
schauen wir müssen bei Subvention genau
gucken wie die verteilungswirkung
wirklich ist mal so sagen wenn man
Bauern fördert ich glaube die Bauern die
stehen jetzt nicht gerade ganz oben da
etwa auf der eommenskala in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland man muss
gucken mein das war mein Hauptbestreben
es gibt viele Subventionen die nach dem
Motto verteilt werden wer hat dem wird
gegeben das trifft mit Sicherheit auf
die Bauern nicht zu und mein petitum war
insbesondere in der Tat mal zu schauen
ob die Subventionen tatsächlich den
Zweck erreichen den sie vorgeblich
erreichen sollten ich glaube es gibt
eine Menge Subventionen wo das nicht der
Fall ist bei den Landwirten sind die
Subventionen tatsächlich Teil eines
Einkommens das ja in der Regel nicht
sonderlich groß ist das hängt immer
natürlich ein bisschen auch von der
Betriebsgröße zusammen da aber dass die
dass die Bauern ganz oben stehen da und
dass insoweit die Subventionen sag wir
dazu führen dass der Grundsatz W hat
wird eben gilt das kann man glaube ich
bei den Agrarsubventionen nicht
behaupten es gibt noch eine kleine
subventionsergänzung ja ich will nur
weil wir uns so prima ergänzen immer
wollte ich noch mal ergänzen was Thomas
sagt als Beispiel also Bauern die jetzt
weniger Pestizide verteilen und die
sagen wir machen ökologische
Landwirtschaft die müssen öfters aufs
Feld fahren das heißt bei denen ist z.B
Agrar diese Subvention hat auch eine
Rolle für die ökologische Landwirtschaft
deswegen finde ich es manchmal auch so
einfach wie dann der Abbau ökologischer
Pension diskutiert wird also darauf muss
man auch achten Herr Jung und dann Herr
Vollrad
ichgeschrieben am Anfang gesagt wir
haben die Partei Vernunft und
Gerechtigkeit kurz BSW gegründet ich da
die Partei B sknecht warum trauen sie
sich das zu sagen war eine Partei mit
diesem Namen kein
Personenkult also ich dchte ich habe den
Namen gesagt aber vielleicht ist er ist
ganz hinten durchgedrogen Bündnis Sarah
Wagenknecht Vernunft und Gerechtigkeit
so heißt die Partei kurz BSW und der
namee wird bis zur Bundestagswahl so
bleiben nach der Bundestagswahl wenn wir
dann auch ein neues Parteiprogramm
beschließen und wenn die Partei dann
wirklich auch konsolidiert ist und
hoffentlich mit einer starken Fraktion
im Bundestag vertreten ist werden wir
einen Namen finden der unabhängig von
meinem persönlichen Namen ist aber es
ist natürlich nicht einfach in
Deutschland eine neue Partei zu
etablieren es fängt damit an dass wir
auf den Wahlzetteln ganz weit unten
stehen und die Leute uns finden müssen
und die Leute nicht unbedingt wenn sie
dann vorher wirklich Z andere 20 andere
Parteinamen finden
das möglicherweise dich identifizieren
können außerdem ist es auch so wir
arbeiten jetzt an einer Programmatik wir
haben sie aber noch nicht ausgefallt
aber ich stehe für viele Menschen für
eine Programmatik sie wissen bei mir
woran sie sind sie wissen wo ich hin
will und da will ja auch die Partei hin
und deswegen hat es für die Anfangsphase
Sinn den Namen von mir in den
Parteinamen reinzunehmen perspektivisch
wird das nicht der Fall sein ich meine
wir gründen eine Partei wir haben auch
gerade vorhin auf der
Gründungsversammlung darüber gesprochen
die soll da das deutsche Parteien System
verändern das heißt sie soll sich für
die nächsten 20 30 40 Jahre etablieren
ich glaube sie nehmen mir ab dass ich
nicht mehr 30 40 Jahre in der
Bundespolitik tätig sein möchte das ist
auch mit meinem Alter nicht ganz zu
Verein waren das heißt wir reden hier
auch über eine Partei die natürlich
perspektivisch auch völlig unabhängig
von mir weiter bestehen wird und das
wird sich dann natürlich auch direkt
schon nach der Bundestagswahl da bin ich
dann noch dabei aber trotzdem im Namen
widerspiegeln 80jährigen
obpräsident aber Programmatik ich habe
auch gescheben heiungsgesetzesmist
verbrennerverbot ist Mist waen Ukraine
sind Mist Asylrecht ist Mist könen un z
papunkte
die das BSW von der AF unterscheiden
wird also ich glaube den den Begriff
Mist habe ich hier noch gar nicht
verwendet das ist jetzt ihre
Zusammenfassung ich denke dass ich
vorhin sehr deutlich gesagt habe was wir
z.B in der Migrationspolitik verändern
wollen wir wollen die Zahlen reduzieren
wir wollen aber auch dass perspektiv in
den Heimatländern entstehen ich habe
davon bei der AFD noch nichts gehört wir
wollen dass Kriege beendet werden dass
sie diplomatisch gelöst werden die AFD
ist eine Partei die generell sehr wohl
für Rüstungsexporte ist wenn sie der
deutschen Industrie helfen also da das
ist ja eine ganz andere Positionierung
also ich glaube nicht dass ich jetzt
durchdeklinieren muss wenn sie sich die
Wirtschafts- und Sozialpolitik angucken
wir haben vorhin gesprochen über soziale
Gerechtigkeit
sie finden einfach im deutschen
Parteienspektrum zu meinem großen
Bedauern keine Partei mehr die sich
ernsthaft für diese Fragen gute Löhne
ordentliche Renten ein starker
Sozialstaat einsetzt also ich meine auch
die rententhematik also ich weiß nicht
wie trut sie mit der AFD Programmatik
sind wir haben eine Situation in
Deutschland wo man nach über 40 Jahren
einzahlen eine Durchschnittsrente von
1445 € bekommen und wir haben eine
Oppositionspartei die CDU die will das
Enten Eintrittsalter erhöhen das heißt
sie will die Renten noch weiter kürzen
und wir haben eine AFD die auch in dem
Bereich eher für privatwirtschaftliche
Lösungen kapitalgedeckte Rente und
ähnliches Eintritt
das ist sozusagen wenn meine die Haik
Gesellschaft der Frau Weidel angehört
ist jetzt nicht dafür bekannt für einen
starken Sozialstaat und starke
Umlagesysteme zu werben also gerade
dieses Thema ist natürlich eins das auch
ein Grund war warum wir diese Partei
gegründet haben weil die Menschen ihre
Brot und Butter Themen die Themen die
ihr ganz alltägliches Leben ausmachen
dass sie gut bezahlt werden dass ihre
Arbeitsplätze sicher sind dass sie aber
auch nicht Angst haben müssen im Alter
arm zu sein dass sie in Wohnungen leben
deren mieten Sie bezahlen können sagen
Sie mir welche von den anderen Parteien
dafür stehen also die AFD bestimmt nicht
dass man mieten reguliert und dass man
hier auch da eingreift in den Markt
alsooweit finde ich wir können da in
sehr vielen Punkten wir werden in Kürze
unser europawahlprogramm vorlegen das
wird ja auch ein viel detaillierteres
Programm noch mal sein als das aktuelle
Parteiprogramm wenn Sie das neben die
Programme anderer Parteien legen glaube
ich werden sich keine Fragen mehr
stellen wo die Unterschiede sind ich
würde gern wenn ich darf dazu noch ein
einen Aspekt noch mal etwas weiter
hervorheben weil sie es gesagt haben
jung also Asylrecht ist Mist ist nicht
unsere Position selbstverständlich und
das hat s wagencht ja auch ausgeführt
Geis das ausgeführt wollen wir dass die
Menschen die ein einen Grund haben Asyl
zu bekommen dass die auch entsprechend
ein Asylrecht bekommen was wir sagen ist
dass die aktuelle Ausgestaltung des
Asylrechts und insgesamt die aktuelle
Ausgestaltung die migrationsregelungen
ungeeignet dafür sind das vernünftig zu
reglementieren und auch denjenigen die
Anspruch auf Asyl haben
dieses Recht zukommen zu lassen wir
erleben das ja dass viele Menschen
jahrelang in Verfahren festsetzen und in
der Tat diejenigen die einülgrund haben
schaffen es oft gar nicht hierher das
sind große Probleme die es gibt aber
selbstverständlich ist unsere Position
dass Menschen die poliitch verfolgt
werden die einen Anspruch darauf haben
geschützt zu werden dass die diesen
Schutz auch erhalten das mir auch
persönlich wichtig dass das nicht falsch
verstanden
wird ich ma mal eine kleine
zwischenansage wir haben ich habe jetzt
noch 15 Fragen die offen sind wir haben
fast eine Stunde jetzt und wir haben
sechs Fragen bis jetzt sozusagen
durchgenommen und ich würde alle
irgendwie so ein bisschen um Disziplin
und zeitdisziplin bringen sie wollten
gleich wohl ergänzen Herr demasi ja ich
wollte ergänzen so ein bisschen nach dem
Motto meine Antwort passt jetzt nicht
hundertprozentig zur Frage von jung aber
ich versuch es trotzdem mal also ich
habe in den letzten vielleicht warten
Sie einfach auf die nächste Frage wenn
die dann ich wer schon werde schon auf
die gestellte Frage eingehen ich will es
nur ergänzen ich will sie erweitern
sozusagen ich habe in den letzten Tag
erlebt dass auch Leute die mir immer
früher juvial auf die Schultern geklopft
haben auf einmal eine Riesenwelle
gemacht haben die haben alle Beifall
gespendet als ich aus der linken raus
bin und sagen jetzt jetzt bist du einer
Partei da bist du irgendwie Russland nah
oder rechtsnational also ich will
erstmal sagen zu meiner persönlichen
Biografie mein Großvater war in Italien
Widerstandskämpfer ich würde niemals in
eine Partei eintreten die rechtsnational
wäre so weil ich nur diese Labels immer
mitbekomme das ist das erste das zweite
ist ähm zu dem Vorwurf z. der Russland
Nähe das will ich ja einfach nur mal
sagen also in meinem Fall ich war
während meiner Wirecard Recherchen
im Fokus eines mutmaßlichen russischen
Spions V österreichischen
Verfassungsschutz ich habe im Alleingang
da hat sich keine andere Partei in
diesem Bundestag für interessiert
offengelegt dass der Cyber Security
Investor der unter anderem die
Kommunikation von Herrn Scholz
verschlüsselte enge Verbindung zu Herrn
Malek dessen fluchthelfern und
vermutlich auch dem oder zumindest
russland hat ich habe einen ehemaligen
generalalkonsul Russlands der
mittlerweile nicht mehr in Deutschland
Generalkonsul ist da habe ich
offengelegt dass der wegen
Spionageverdacht aus Österreich
herausgewiesen wurde und das wissen die
meisten kollegenin Kollegen der Medien
nicht ich musste in Südafrika mein Auto
in Einzelteile zerlegen lassen vom
Mechaniker weil ich bestimmte Drohungen
im Rahmen meiner Recherchen erhalten
habe deswegen finde ich das in Farm wenn
teilweise diese Vorwürfe erhoben werden
und ich werde auch im Wahlkampf ich habe
da ja noch so ganzes Notizbuch voll
mal ein bisschen öffentlich machen und
darstellen wer alles z.B Gelder bekommen
hat also die FDP hat z.B teilweise
Konten gehabt bei der
wirecardbank da sind Spenden denn ihr
den ihr Fundraiser vom Tegernsee hat äh
sozusagen burghardlei der jetzt des
bandenbetrugs angeklagt äh ist von also
das war der Chief Financial Officer von
WC den hat er mit irgendwelchen
kremelnahen Milliardären
zusammengebracht also das sehe ich mit
großer Gelassenheit und bei uns gab es
dann eine Debatte
m über Finanzierung aus dem Ausland und
Russland und dann stellt sich heraus es
waren 50 € mit einer deutschen e-bahn
und noch mal 25 € die anhand der
IP-Adresse Russland zuordnet werden
konnten ich war derjenige ich habe sogar
meine Steuererklärung veröffentlicht in
dieser Ecke in die wir da teilweise
gestellt werden das ist wirklich von den
Fakten nicht gedeckt und abschließend zu
der Frage der
Migration ich glaube hier sitzen
mindestens
vier Personen die zumindest teilweise
ein Zuwanderungshintergrund haben auf
dem
Podium und ich will dazu nur sagen dass
das Asylrecht V uns gilt ist völlig klar
das Problem ist nur dass das Asylrecht
alleine auch die Ungerechtigkeiten in
der Welt nicht heilt also als Beispiel
wenn ich jetzt ein politisch aktiver
Islamist in Ägypten bin und verfol werde
von C hätte ich Anspruch in Deutschland
auf Asyl wenn ich aber Sudanese bin und
verhungere habe ich das nicht so
deswegen ist klar dass die Zuwanderung
nicht allein die Probleme der
Ungleichheit in der Welt löst ist klar
dass sie vereinige eine Verbesserung der
Lebenssituation herbeiführen kann aber
nicht für alle deswegen finde ich die
Verlogenheit also ich kenne Leute in
Deutschland die sagen sie würden eine
offene
Asylpolitik betreiben aber die finden es
völlig okay was derzeit in Gaza passiert
und das sind Widersprüche will ich nur
drauf hindeuten und deswegen ist für uns
klar wir werden sagen wir wollen
natürlich jene die keinen Anspruch haben
auf Asyl da müssen wir ein Umgang mit
finden und jene die sich hier integriert
haben die Job haben die brauchen auch
Planungssicherheit in ihrem Leben den
werden wir keine Knüppel zwischen die
Beine werfen aber natürlich müssen wir
die Zahlen reduzieren und zwar in dem
Sinne auch dass wir natürlich
finanzielle Anstrengung unternehmen dass
in den Herkunftsländern die Situation
stabilisiert
wird Herr und dann hier vorne weiter
runter
ja ich muss auch noch mal auf die Leiche
Thema
gesbiografieommen ja in der
Vergangenheit ter vorgeworen Word sie
sein rechts offen wollte noch mal fragen
wie offen sind sie vor Hintergrund dass
diese Woche die rer Luxemburg Konferenz
wieder
stattfindet und da wird unter anderem
Sozialismus als Alternative angepriesen
und das trittaler Terrorist aus Dänemark
auch aber auch ihre Parteifreundin von
nastisch wie passt das zu ihrem eigenen
Anspruch dass sie äh Menschen die die
AFD wählen nicht weil sie rechts sondern
weil sie verzweifelt sind dass ihen ein
seriöses politisches Angebot machen
wollen wieem
Anspruch also ich sehe keinen
Widerspruch darin dass Mitglieder von
uns auf Konferenzen auftreten wo wir
sicherlich nicht das Gesamtprogramm
unterstützen oder gut heißen sondern wo
wir einfach oder wo einige von uns einen
Beitrag leisten also ich bin jetzt gar
nicht mit dem Programm genau vertraut
der Roser Luxemburg Konferenz ich weiß
dass das jedes Jahr stattfindet und dass
da sicherlich auch sehr viele Dinge
angesprochen werden die unserem Anliegen
sehr nahe sind also beispielsweise die
Frage von Frieden die Frage von
Entspannung auch die Frage von sozialer
Gerechtigkeit und dann gibt es
vielleicht auch Punkte die wir nicht so
sehen aber das spricht ja nicht dagegen
auf einer Konferenz aufzutreten also ich
persönlich war schon bei vielen
Konferenzen auch solchen die auch von
Wirtschaftsorganisationen äh organisiert
wurden wo jetzt auch nicht alle Beiträge
auf dem Podium äh irgendwie jetzt meine
Ideologie widerspiegeln also wo kommen
wir denn hin wenn wir gar nicht mehr ins
Gespräch kommen wenn wir gar keine
Debatten mehr führen oder wenn wir uns
einegeln und sagen wir gehen nirgendwo
mehr hin wo nicht alle genauso denken
wie wir also ich glaube das ist eher ein
Problem in Deutschland dass immer
weniger debattiert wird dass immer
weniger man in der Lage ist miteinander
zu reden auch wenn man unterschiedliche
Meinungen hat zu wichtigen Fragen oder
auch zu weniger wichtigen Fragen und das
deswegen da zu sein ins Gespräch zu
kommen zu diskutieren heißt ja nicht
dass man immer da wo man auftaucht alles
teilt was dort sonst gesagt
wird dann geht's bitte dort weiter sie
hat sich do
gemeldet der Kollege noch dahinter ja
hatten sie hatten sich doch gemeldet
bitte die Land angesprochen die hat ja
heute begonnen Plan sie selbst von den
Land zu sprechen oder jemand anderes aus
dem bsirkel der jetzt hier vor uns sitzt
es gibt zahlreich Veranstaltung der Nähe
also wenn ich angefragt werde bin ich
dazu gerne bereit also bisher gibt es da
noch keine engeren Kontakte aber ich
teile das Anliegen ich halte es auch für
absolut wichtig dass die Landwirte hier
ihre Interessen so prominent vertreten
weil ich denke es ist in unser aller
Interesse dass es weiterhin in
Deutschland Landwirtschaft gibt und zwar
nicht nur durch große Agrarkonzerne die
sind ja am ist noch relativ safe weil
die natürlich ein anderes
Wirtschaftsmodell haben aber wir erleben
seit Jahren dass die Höfe sterben ich
kenne das ich wohne ja auf dem Dorf ich
bin mit den Landwirten dort im Kontakt
ich habe mit ihnen gesprochen und die
haben mir wirklich sehr detailliert
erläutert welcher regelungswust aus
Berlin ihnen das Leben noch schwerer
macht als es ohnehin schon ist und ich
finde das so können wir mit Menschen die
unsere Lebensmittel produzieren nicht
umgehen ich möchte nicht dass wir
irgendwann unsere ganzen Lebensmittel
aus dem Ausland importieren müssen weil
hier nichts mehr angebaut wird und ich
möchte auch nicht dass nur noch
Agrarkonzerne Landwirtschaft in
Deutschland betreiben ich finde es
wertvoll dass es die Höfe gibt dass es
familiengführte Betriebe gibt und ich
finde wir alle sollten diesen Menschen
dankbar sein das ist eine verdammt harte
Arbeit da kann man nicht mal eben
mehrere Wochen irgendwann in Urlaub
fahren weil man einfach vor Ort sein
muss wir sollten diesen Menschen dankbar
sein dass sie diesen Job machen und wir
sollten ihnen das Leben leichter machen
und nicht immer schwerer und die Art und
Weise wie die Ampel jetzt da mal eben
dreifach sie hat jetzt teilweise
zurückgenommen aber zunächst mal war so
richtig dort Belastungen hingewälzt hat
weil sie dachte da wird schon nichts
passieren die Landwirte haben keine
starke Lobby das fande ich wirklich
unerträglich und ich bin froh dass die
Menschen sich jetzt whren weil es in
unserem Interesse ist
auch noch eine Nachfrage ja also dass
die Landwirte keine gute Lobby haben das
scheint ja gar nicht so zu sein wenn die
Bundesregierung darauf reagiert und
jetzt schon einzelne Vorhaben
zurügenommen zu haben ja gut die
Landwirte haben jetzt deutlich gemacht
dass sie sich das nicht gefallen lassen
und natürlich sind Traktoren hier in
Berlin Mitte schon auch ein eine
Demonstration von macht weil man damit
auch deutlich machen kann oder auch in
anderen Teilen des Landes dass man sehr
wohl nicht der also nicht bereit ist
bestimmte Dinge einfach zu schlucken
dadurch haben sie jetzt Veränderungen
erreicht aber wie gesagt im Vorfeld muss
man ja deutlich sagen hatte das Paket
das Sparpaket der Ampel erstmal für die
Landwirtschaft ja wirklich nur
unerfreuliche Überraschungen und das
scheint ja so zu sein dass hier in
Berlin zunächst mal vielleicht auch weil
Landwirtschaft weit weg ist man dachte
mit denen könnte man es machen und die
Menschen die Bauern die Landwirte haben
gezeigt mit ihnen kann man es nicht
machen zeigt auch dass Protest sinnvoll
und wichtig ist und zu einer Demokratie
unbedingt dazu
gehört ich hätte eine kurze Frage an
Herr demasi und her Geis ähm und zwar
haben wir schon gehört nichtert als
linkszeichnen will aber Blick auflament
gibt schon Überlegung welcheaktion
anschließen könnte ganz konkret kann man
sich
vorstellen Fraktion
europäis ja vielen Dank für die Frage
also ich komme aus einer politischen
Traditionslinie die im weitesten Sinne
links ist nur viele Menschen
verstehen etwas anderes unter dem Label
Links ausgeführt also früher war das der
Konflikt zwischen oben und unten sage
ich mal im weitesten Sinne das wird
häufig darunter nicht mehr verstanden
aber ich trete natürlich habe ja nicht
jetzt meine meine Überzeugung wie eine
Unterhose gewechselt oder so die Frage
welche Fraktionen da stehen eine
spannende Frage ich bin mir noch nicht
mal sicher dass es z.B die Linksfraktion
im Europäischen Parlament
in der nächsten Legislaturperiode geben
wird es gibt ja z.B auch in der früheren
griechischen Linkspartei Spaltung und so
weiter und so fort das wissen wir nicht
nach meiner Kenntnis ist die
Voraussetzung für eine Fraktion äh ich
glaube 23 oder 25 Abgeordnete aus sieben
Mitgliedstaaten müsste ich noch mal
nachschlagen aber das ist so ungefähr
ähm die Schwelle und das ist gar nicht
so eine einfache Schwelle für uns ist
entscheidend dass wir mit politischen
Partnern agieren ähm die zwar immer
etwas unterschiedlich sind auf der
europäischen Ebene ist normal aber wo
wir sagen da gibt es ein politischen
Korridor hinter dem wir uns versammeln
können das ist das entscheidende
Kriterium ich vermute das würde in der
bisherigen Zusammensetzung
der der der früheren Linksfraktion dort
Probleme bereiten weil wir auch eine
neue politische Kraft sind aber
vielleicht findet sich ja auch was neues
Herr
grim am liebsten nach vorne sonst dreht
man dem den Hals um chran von der
augsburgercht ich wollte Sie fragen
warum sie nicht als Spitzen Kandidaten
für das die allemin kidieren und a
überhaupt sich für die dieses für einen
für einen Sitz in diesem Parlament
bewerben also zum einen weil wir zwei
sehr gute Spitzenkandidaten haben und
ich denke dass da also wirklich auch
unser Profil und unsere inhaltlichen
Überzeugungen sehr deutlich werden zum
anderen aber eben auch also weil
natürlich mein Platz im Bundestag ist
wir werden wir haben einen gruppenstatus
beantragt ich hoffe dass wir jetzt das
sind die Signale zumindest die wir haben
in einer der ersten Sitzungswochen
vielleicht hoffentlich die dieser Status
auch bewilligt ist ich bin bewilligt
wird ich bin bereits als
gruppenvorsitzende gewählt worden von
unseren Zeh
Abgeordneten und natürlich möchte ich
vor allem hier im Bundestag Politik
machen für die Menschen hier im Land
auch die Europawahl um das deutlich zu
sagen ist natürlich auch für uns deshalb
so wichtig weil sie auch ein
bundespolitisches Signal aussenden wird
also wir müssen bei der Europawahl
natürlich möchten wir wir haben werden
eine sehr gute Liste aufstellen wir
werden da auch noch noch einige
Überraschung präsentieren die glaube ich
schon sehr deutlich zeigen in welcher
Breite wir sind also es ist auch
sozusagen nicht nötig weil wir auch
wirklich viele gute Kandidatinnen und
Kandidaten haben werden auf der Liste
aber es wird für uns nicht nur darum
gehen in in dem Europawahlkampf darum zu
kämpfen dass wir möglichst viele
Menschen in die ins Europaparlament dass
viele Menschen gewählt werden von
unserer Liste sondern es geht natürlich
auch um das bundespolitische Signal
deswegen werde ich mich in diesem
Wahlkampf auch sehr engagieren es ist
völlig da wenn BSW bei der Europawahl
stark abschneidet dann ist das auch ein
Signal an die Ampel dann kann das in
Deutschland etwas verändern es ist auch
natürlich wichtig dann für die folgenden
Landtagswahlen soweit ich werde viel in
diesem Wahlkampf dabei sein ich werde
viel in diesem Wahlkampf machen aber es
wäre nicht ehrlich gewesen zu
kandidieren wenn ich nicht dann
ernsthaft auch in Brüssel und und
Straßburg gearbeitet hätte also sprich
wenn ich das Mandat angenommen hätte und
beide Mandate sind im Grunde nicht
vereinbar so ich spring jetzt in die
Mitte zu Herrn Haug noch eine
Migrationsfrage wir doch eiglich
unkonkret grundsätzlich die Frage wollen
sie eine Obergrenze also sie wollen
außerhalb der Europäischen Union die
Situation für die Menschen verbessern
dafür Geld hernehmen aber wollen sie
beispielsweise sollen dass wir eine eine
Obergrenze pro jah Herr Geisel hat
angesprochen dass die Kommunen h V nicht
damit klar kommen sie etwas
konkretisieren was sie sich da konkret
vorstellen ja es geht ja nicht um eine
formale Obergrenze sondern es geht darum
dass die Zahlen sich deutlich reduzieren
müssen und dass ein Großteil derer die
jetzt nach Deutschland kommen eben auch
keinen asylanspruch haben also das wird
ja nach diesen langen Verfahren die wir
in Deutschland machen die allerdings
dann meistens schon über ein Jahr
manchmal zwei Jahre manchmal länger in
Anspruch nehmen am Ende auch klar also
1% derer die nach Deutschland kommen von
denen die Asylanträge Stellen bekommen
auch einen Asylstatus und deswegen sagen
wir wir möchten die Asylverfahren an die
europäischen Außengrenzen verlagern wir
möchten Sie auch in Drittstaaten
stattfinden lassen damit Menschen nicht
danach selektiert werden ob sie erst mal
das Geld für die Schlepper aufbringen
können das ist ja ein ganz wichtiger
Aspekt also ich habe vorhin erwähnt wenn
man aus Afghanistan ich finde das
übrigens nach wie vor absolut schäbig
wie wir die Leute dort im Stich gelassen
haben voror vorige Woche eine Mail
bekommen noch mal von jemanden der sich
massiv der massiv bedroht ist jetzt von
den Taliban der sich völlig im Stich
gelassen fühlt vom Außenamt vom
Außenministerium und er sagt was mache
ich denn jetzt und das ist jemand der
kann keine teuren Schlepper bezahlen so
natürlich müsste es für solche Menschen
eine Möglichkeit geben wirklich auch
Schutz zu bekommen also die ganze
Asylpolitik die wir erleben ist ja
zutiefst unehrlich weil viele die
wirklich bedroht sind bekommen kein Asyl
weil sie gar nicht den Weg gar nicht
sich auf den Weg machen können und
andere die das eben aufbringen können
die kommen hier an dann gibt es lange
Verfahren und in der Regel ist es so
wenn man einmal in Deutschland ist das
ist ja ein Teil des
sogfaktors dann bleibt man zum großen
Teil hier weil egal wie der Asylstatus
ist und das ist ein eine völlig falsche
Asylpolitik es ist auch etwas was die
Menschen im Land nicht mehr akzeptieren
wir sehen in anderen europäischen
Ländern dass sich Parallelgesellschaften
dort massiv schon verfestigt haben in
Frankreich ist das ein großes Problem wo
wirklich ganze Stadt für eigentlich
nicht mehr die französische Gesellschaft
wiederspiegeln wir haben das in
Deutschland noch nicht so stark aber wir
müssen auch gucken dass wir nie dahin
kommen weil das wirklich eine
hochbedenkliche Entwicklung ist und man
muss natürlich auch sagen die ganzen
Probleme die mit misslungener
Integration zu tun haben die wälzen wir
auf die ärmeren ab weil es sind die
ärmeren Wohngebiete wo sich das abspielt
wo in den Schulen eben über die Hälfte
der Kinder kein Deutsch kann und die
Lehrer verzweifeln wo dann Wohnungen
fehlen wo wo die Infrastruktur
überfordert ist das fängt ja schon bei
kitaitapätzen an also all diese Probleme
die gibt es die sind jahrelang von der
Politik geleugnet worden so hat man auch
die AFD stark gemacht weenn man so getan
hat das sein das keine Probleme es sind
aber welche und deswegen müssen die Zahl
muss die Zahl derer die nach Deutschland
kommt wir sehen da auch durchaus
Dänemark als Vorbild erstmal um auf
nationaler Ebene handlungsfähig zu sein
die Zahl muss reduziert werden und zwar
nicht z latzen derer die wirklich
verfolgt werden son dann eben zu len
derer die aus nachvollziehbaren Gründen
ein besseres Leben suchen aber das kann
Deutschland nicht gewährleisten wir
können das Problem der weltweiten Armut
nicht durch Migration lösen zus ich noch
mal andersum wollen sie an
Sozialleistungen die geflüchtete die
Asylbewerber möglicherweise bekommen
Kürzungen vornehmen auch beispielsweise
dass die Ukrainer Anrecht auf Bürgergeld
haben es wird ja häufig davon gesprochen
dass es insbesondere eben soziale
Anreize sind die die Menschen nach
Deutschland bringen würden also wollen
sie hier konkret Kürzungen ven ja
zunächst was das Bürgergeld angeht das
ist ja auch eine eine Ungleichbehandlung
also andere bekommen das nicht und es
ist teilweise sogar eine
Ungleichbehandlung gegenüber deutschen
bürgergeldempfängern wo viele Dinge
kontrolliert werden die bei Ukrainern
und Ukrain nicht kontrolliert werden das
empört auch Menschen aber
selbstverständlich wenn Menschen aus
einem Krieg fliehen da wo die
Kriegsgebiete sind in der Ukraine
natürlich müssen die Menschen dort weg
und natürlich muss man ihnen helfen also
das ist ja ein ein ein grauenvoller
Krieg und Zivilisten die fliehen können
und fliehen sollten den muss man
natürlich dann auch Unterstützung geben
und sollte jetzt auch nicht darüber
reden was ja die ukrainische Regierung
gerne möchte dass die Männer jetzt alle
ausgeliefert werden damit sie dann an
die Front gehen aber unser Hauptanliegen
jetzt wenn sie Ukraine ansprechen ist
natürlich dass dieser Krieg sehr bald
endet und dann natürlich sich auch der
Fluchtgrund dadurch erledigt und es ist
ja schon interessant dass inzwischen
auch die amerikanischen Medien überall
darüber reden dass man jetzt eine
Verhandlungslösung anstreben muss dass
tatsächlich es auch Möglichkeiten gibt
diesen Krieg auf dem Verhandlungsweg zu
beenden während in Deutschland einige
wahnsinnige jetzt noch mal die Lieferung
von taurusraketen fordern also inoweit
ja dieser Krieg sollte und muss
möglichst bald beendet werden und das
ist unser Hauptanliegen was diese Frage
angeht das würde also er muss vor allem
geendet werden um das menschliche Leid
zu beenden nicht um Geld zu sparen aber
es würde ganz nebenher auch einen sehr
erheblichen Teil der Kosten die wir
jetzt natürlich tragen um diese Menschen
zu unterstützen die würden dadurch ja
natürlich dann auch wegfallen genauso
wie das viele Geld was wir jetzt für
Waffenlieferung verpulvern Herr sie
möchte noch ergänzen
und Ton ja ich will noch mal
unterstreichen was Frau gesagt hat also
wir tun manchmal so als würden die
Waffen die jetzt auch in die Ukraine
geliefert werden nicht auf ukrainisem
Terium verschossen die werden auf
ukrainischen Territorium verschossen das
heißt die betreffen natürlich auch
unmittelbar die Menschen die dort leben
natürlich hat die Ukrainer ein Recht auf
die Selbstverteidigung aber es gibt ja
mittlerweile auch
ukrainische Unterhändler die gesagt
haben man war im März 2022 sehr nah an
einer Lösung und deswegen glaube ich
muss Europa da dringend mehr
diplomatische Initiative zeigen was die
Geldleistung angeht will ich auch noch
mal auf einen Aspekt eingehen also
entscheidend ist natürlich Menschen die
be uns leben die müssen gut unterstützt
werden damit Integration gelingen kann
und das ist nicht allein eine Frage des
Geldes deswegen gibt es auch die
Kapazitäten weil natürlich selbst wenn
man jetzt viel Geld in die Hand nimmt es
müssen genug Schulgebäude zur Verfügung
stellen es muss genug Wohnraum zur
Verfügung stehen das geht auch nicht
über Nacht und man braucht qualifizierte
Lehrer und so weiter und so fort aber
für diejenigen Menschen die jetzt kein
asylanspruch haben ähm da ist natürlich
schon die Frage wenn man nicht die
Bundesregierung also der Kanzler lässt
sich jetzt ablisten auf dem Spiegelcover
mit wir müssen irgendwie möglichst viele
Menschen abschieben das ist aber schon
logistisch sozusagen will ich mal sehen
wie wir die ganzen Menschen wo wir
unaufgeklärten ungeklärten Status etc
haben wie das funktionieren soll
deswegen müssen wir natürlich Maßnahmen
ergreifen dass wir gerade diejenigen die
jetzt kein asylanspruch haben und zu uns
kommen dass wir die Anreize dort
verringern da gibt's immer die
Diskussion über die pullfaktoren da
sagen die ein das hat gar nichts mit
finanziellen Anreizen zu tun sondern
eher mit persönlichen Netzwerken die
spielen natürlich eine Rolle aber die
bilden sich ja auch oder dass Menschen
aus bestimmten Ländern kommen und dann
ein Netzwerk vorhanden ist weil sie
natürlich aus verständlichen Gründen
meinen dass sie hier besser ihr Leben
sichern können und das Problem ist ja
Menschen die dann in so einer unsicheren
Perspektive sind über über lange Zeit
weil sie eben keinen geklärten Status
haben die können sich auch kein Leben
aufbauen und da ich habe ja auch die
Entwürfe gesehen das wird alles noch
vorgestellt auch uns europawahlprogramm
aber klar ist dass wir natürlich auch
sagen diejenigen die jetzt hier
mittlerweile ein Job haben sich eine
Perspektive aufgebaut haben denen
sollten wir auch keine Knüppel zwischen
die Beine werfen aber wir müssen da was
tun und weil man nämlich ansonsten die
AFD eben auf dem Niveau hat wo man sie
jetzt hat und da kann man sich dann
hinstellen und sagen
man führt diese Debatten nicht die
längst in der Ampel geführt werden am
Ende ist man dann aber der ernterhelfer
der AFD und das werde ich mit Sicherheit
nicht seinin wollen wir rücken eine
weiter eine Reihe weiter vor ich es geht
jetzt hier reinweise nach vorne sie
haben das Wort ja ja und das Mikro
müsste leuchten
oder eine Wagenknecht von Politikum sie
haben gesagt sie sind zuversichtlich
dass sie bei den Wahlen in
Ostdeutschland antreten werden wovon
hängt
das also die Menschen erwarten dass wir
antreten und deswegen gehe ich
eigentlich auch davon aus dass wir das
leisten selbstverständlich kann man nur
antreten wenn man in allen jedem
einzelnen dieser drei Bundesländer eine
solide kompetente Liste für die
Landtagswahlen hat also man braucht
nicht irgendwie Leute die da kandidieren
die haben wir bestimmt und sofort
sondern man braucht ja wirklich ganz
kompetente Menschen die unterschiedliche
Themenfelder abdecken und die dann im
Landtag auch eine kompetente Arbeit
machen also ich meine es gibt schon
Parteien auch immer mal gerade bei
Neugründung ist das nicht selten die
schicken dann irgendjemanden in den
Landtag und danach sind alle entsetzt
wenn Sie gewählt haben sowas wird uns
nicht passieren wir werden Listen
aufstellen mit lauter kompetenten
Menschen und ich kann zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt im Grunde sagen ich gehe davon
aus dass wir das schaffen aber das ist
die entscheidende Voraussetzung also wir
brauchen dort und da reden wir ja
wirklich durchaus so über 30
40 Listenkandidaten wir reden über
Bundesländer wo selbst eine
Regierungsbeteiligung jetzt nicht
ausgeschlossen ist also wir müssen ja
gucken wenn man sich die Wahlergebnisse
wie sie w wscheinlich aussehen werden
anguckt ist das ja nicht ganz jenseits
der Reichweite also braucht man dort
Menschen die das können die das Handwerk
verstehen aus unterschiedlichen
Bereichen die müssen nicht alle
professionelle Politiker sein das wollen
wir auch gar nicht aber sie müssen in
der Lage sein die Aufgaben zu bewältigen
die da auf sie zukommen und das müssen
wir gewährleisten aber ich glaube das
können wir Kollegin in der
Mitte ja weil sie schon zweimal
angesprochen haben dass weniger als 1%
der aslantrig positive chieden würden
also wenn man einmal schnell duelt auf
der Seite der Bundeszentrale politische
Bildung findet man die Zahl dass die
Anerkennungsquote oder bzw die Quote der
positiv beschienenen Asylanträge im
letzten Jahr bei 51,8% L vielleicht
können Sie kurz sagen wie sie auf die
unter 1%
kommen also da muss ich eher
zurückfragen wie sie auf 50% kommen also
ich habe mehr also ich habe die
Statistiken gelesen es gibt zusätzlich
noch einen Schutzstatus also den
sogenannten subsidiären Schutz das ist
etwas anderes als der Asylstatus der
Asylstatus ist unter 1% der der
Schutzstatus das sind dann eben z.B
Menschen die aus Syrien kommen die
bekommen nicht das Recht auf Asyl
sondern sie bekommen diesen vorläufigen
Schutzstatus wobei eben bei Syrien ja
auch die Frage ist wieso wir dieses Land
weiter durch Wirtschaftssanktionen in
Grund und Boden drangalieren um dann in
Kauf zu nehmen dass die Menschen zu uns
kommen weil sie zu Hause keine
Perspektive mehr haben ist ja nicht der
Bürgerkrieg es ist auch nicht die
politische Verfolgung srien war immer
eine Diktatur trotzdem gab es nie in
dieser Größenordnung politische
Fluchtbewegungen sind ja jetzt
inzwischen mit die größte Gruppe wenn
ich mal von den Ukrainern absehe das hat
ja etwas damit zu tun wie es in diesem
Land jetzt aussieht also das ist keine
Asyl keine das sind keine Asylsuchenden
sondern das sind Menschen die kriegen
einen Schutzstatus den man allerdings
auch verhindern könnte wenn wir z.B
durch Aufhebung der
Wirtschaftssanktionen dazu beitragen
würden dass vor Ort wieder ein
Wiederaufbau möglich ist ja dazu kommen
ja auch noch die Leute die nach der ger
Flüchtlingskonvention als Flüchtlinge
anerkannt werden also
wir reden glaube ich von denen die eben
nach dem deutschen Asylrecht anerkannt
werden aber das ist ja nur ein kleiner
Teil und die anderen haben trotzdem ja
auch nach der Entscheidung des banks ein
recht eben 51,8% hab ein Recht und haben
Schutzbedürfnisse die erstmal anerkannt
werden also genau da wollte ich nur kurz
darauf hinweisen vielleicht ein bisschen
irreführen ist ne wir haben ja vorhin
über das individuelle Recht auf Asyl
gesprochen also das war die
ausdrückliche Frage es ging nicht um die
anderen Schutzbedürfnisse sondern es
ging um dieses individuelle Asylrecht
und auch Sie haben Recht die Hälfte
bekommt erstmal diesen vorläufigen
Status aber das zeigt auch die andere
Hälfte hat die nicht und trotzdem ist
der übergroße Teil nach wie vor in
Deutschland das müssen wir auch sehen
also Sie können sich ja angucken wie
viel da wirklich dann in ihre Länder
zurückgehen das ist nicht die andere
Hälfte sondern das ist sehr sehr sehr
viel weniger also auch die von ihnen
gezeigte Zahl von ihnen angeführte Zahl
zeigt dass hier vieles im Argen liegt
aber wie gesagt vorin war die Debatte
über Asyl und die Zahl die sie genannt
haben hat mit dem direkten Asylstatus
nichts zu tun eri hat zahlen bereit nee
ich will auch noch mal einem Eindruck
entgegentreten also es ist nicht so dass
der der sagen unser kompletter Kosmos
nur um das Thema Migration sich dreht
weil man ja so zu weilen den Eindruck
gewinnen kann öffentlichen Debatte ich
will nur dran erinnern dass es auch
früher in linken Parteien
also die ganze Frage von nur offene
Grenzen nicht früher eine linke Position
war sondern auch Leute wie Bernie
Sanders sagen das früher gab es mal den
Grundsatz in linken Parteien für das
Recht nicht fliehen zu müssen und das
ist das Recht das
im Mittelpunkt unserer Politik steht was
wir verwirklichen wollen Herr warwig hat
das wor nach den Seiten Frau wenn man
sich so im breit
sympathti und potentiell wer Umfeld um
wird re Wunsch artikuliert dass es zu
Aufarbeitung des regierungshandels in
der coronit verwiesen wird Legitimation
der grundrechtseriffe oder auch die
ganzen
sozialikation intern wiederum das recht
heiß diskutiert wird da mich
interessieren wie ist denn da der Stand
Plan die BSW sich diesema anzehmen
dieinger
weassenin das ist ein G witiges Thema
von uns und das wird auch von uns
aufgemacht werden auch mit
Persönlichkeiten die auch sich bei uns
engagieren es ist jetzt auch schon so
dass selbstverständlich sich auch
Menschen bei uns melden mitzumachen auch
weil sie dieses Thema sehr sehr wichtig
finden weil es geht nicht darum gut man
kann sagen die coronazeit ist vorbei die
Maßnahmen sind vorbei das ist Geschichte
ich halte das für falsch wenn man das
abhakt erstens hat die coronazeit
gezeigt wie massiv Grundrechte in Frage
gestellt wordden ohne dass es eine
valide Begründung dafür gegeben hat das
ist ja im Nachhinein aufgeklärt worden
also die EMA sogar die europäische
Agentur hat deutlich gesagt die Impfung
war nie so konzipiert dass sie einen
fremdschutz gewährleistet wir hatten
aber in Deutschland 2G wir hatten diese
ganzen Drangsalierungen von Menschen die
sich nicht haben die sich die einfach
von ihrem Recht Gebrauch gemacht haben
von Ihrem
Selbstbestimmungsrecht sich gegen die
Impfung zu entscheiden wir hatten
massive grundrechtseinschränk und die
Gerichte sind nicht dagegen vorgegangen
das heißt es ist etwas gewesen äh was
sich jederzeit wiederholen kann und
schon deshalb muss man sich diesem Thema
widmen und es ist auch ein Thema was
immer noch in der Gesellschaft ein
spaltpotenzial hat also es ist ja etwas
also die Menschen die es damals erlebt
haben ich merke das auch immer wieder in
den Reaktionen die haben das ja nicht
einfach mal so weggelegt sondern die
haben oftmals es waren ja viele Bürgerin
und Bürger die gar nicht so politisch
vorher waren die auf einmal erlebt haben
sie wurden aus dem gesamten öffentlichen
Leben ausgegrenzt aus dem gesamten
sozialen Leben das ist für sie eine
Erfahrung wo sie schon von den
Verantwortlichen gerne noch mal wissen
möchten sehen die das immer so oder
vielleicht hat auch der eine oder andere
sich mal zu entschuldigen also ich meine
wir haben heute noch ein
Gesundheitsminister der nachweislich
damals Dinge erzählt hat die nicht
zutreffend sind wenn ich es mal höflich
sage also ich glaube schon dass man
konnte in der Zeit irren natürlich jeder
von uns irrt und gerade als das wir neu
war konnte man massiv irren einfach weil
wir nicht wussten
was das damit auf sich hat welche Folgen
es hat deswegen will ich überhaupt nicht
jetzt im Nachhinein sagen da muss ein
Scherbengericht stattfinden über
diejenigen die damals sich für lockdowns
ausgesprochen haben oder für die
freiheitseinschränkungen aber die
coronazeit war ja länger also ich rede
nicht jetzt über den ersten über das
erste Frühjahr wo man wirklich zunächst
mal einfach aufgrund der Lage sagen
konnte wir wissen nichts wir machen
jetzt erstmal diese Dinge sondern es
ging ja dann weiter es wurden immer
weiter Schulschließungen gemacht in
Deutschland z.B viel mehr als in anderen
Ländern es wurden hier dann später eben
auch diese ganzen Einschränkungen für
die ungeimpften massiv durchgesetzt von
Politikern die heute noch in
Verantwortung sind und ich finde schon
dass es angemessen ist dass das mal
aufgearbeitet wird wie sind eigentlich
damals Entscheidungen zustande gekommen
wie kam es eigentlich das Politiker sich
so selektiv haben beraten lassen nur von
einem ganz gewissen ausgewählten Kreis
von Experten der Ihnen genau das erzählt
hat was sie hören wollten und die
anderen wurden nicht gewählt weil das
ist ja für künftige Krisen wichtig dass
das nicht noch mal passiert und wie
gesagt ich würde mir eigentlich auch
wünschen dass diejenigen die damals
Dinge verordnet oder auch vertreten
haben ich erinnere mich auch an wirklich
üble Sprüche in der Öffentlichkeit
gegenüber Menschen dass die vielleicht
auch mal von sich aus sagen würden es
tut uns leid was wir damals gemacht
haben weil das hat eine ganze Generation
von Kindern ganz
wirklich aus dem aus dem aus dem
bildungsleben zunächst mal rausgedrängt
bis heute ist das nicht aufgeholt und es
wird wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht
aufgeholt also diese PIs Studie die wir
jetzt haben hat ja auch damit zu tun es
hat Menschen aus dem Berufsleben aus dem
also wenn ich jetzt an die Pflegerin und
Pfleger denke aus dem Berufsleben
ausgedrenzt also es sind viele wirklich
sehr sehr schlimme Dinge passiert und
ich finde dass das aufgearbeitet werden
muss frau Mohammed Ali ich würde da
gerne nur einen einen Aspekt ergänzen
ähm was dazu für mich auch gehört oder
für uns auch gehört ist das an der
Stelle weil die richtigen Lehren aus
dieser Zeit gezogen werden das hat
überhaupt nicht stattgefunden wir haben
gesehen dass unser Gesundheitswesen ein
riesen Problem hat dass diejenigen die
die Gesellschaft im Laufen halten und
das waren damals ja besonders auch die
Pflegerinnen und Pfleger dass die
unterbezahlt sind dass die unter der
dieser Überlast ständig leiden es wurde
gesagt dass da was passiert es wurde
gesagt dass die jetzt plötzlich
honoriert werden nichts davon ist
geschehen gar nichts die Situation in
den Krankenhäusern den Kliniken ist
genauso wie vor der coronazeit auch
wahrscheinlich schlechter das gleiche
gilt auch für die Schulen wir haben das
erlebt dass auch Schulschließung
stattfinden mussten auch weil es an
Materialien gefehlt hat weil es an
Räumen gefehlt hat in denen man
vernünftig unterrichten konnte und so
weiter und das sind alles Dinge da kann
man nicht einfach drüber weggehen und
sagen na ja das war halt eine schwere
Zeit nein man muss doch jetzt daraus
lernen und unbedingt alles dafür tun das
sollte so eine Situation Gott Bewahrer
noch mal eintreten dass wir dann besser
vorbereitet sind auch so eine Situation
damit dieser Einschränkungen nicht
wieder stattfinden noch eine ganz kurze
Verständnisfrage an Herrn Demi sie haben
so eins K bisher auch die Aufklärung von
kumex damit sind sie auch zum Teil
bekannt geworden jetzt ist zumindest bei
der Aufzählung ihrer kernpolitischen
Themen als Spitzenkandidat für die
EU-Wahl kam dies Thema jetzt nicht
vormlich interessieren Plan sie auch auf
eu-pitischer Ebene dieses Thema weiter
zu verfolgen ja das
freut mich dass das mal angesprochen
wird ich habe das sogar extra ich habe
sogar vor Christian lei gesagt wenn er
mich vorstellt soll er ja nicht das Wort
com Exel in Mund nehmen weil meine
politische Biographie wird häufig darauf
reduziert und das nervt mich
mittlerweile ganz ehrlich weil ich habe
mir das ja nicht ausgesucht ich bin in
die Politik gegangen um zu gestalten ich
wollte jetzt nicht immer die Nervensäge
sein die jetzt irgendwie den Leuten die
Finanzskandale unter die Nase hält ist
hat halt nur keiner so richtig gemacht
so und dann habe ich mich drum gekümmert
das fing Europäischen Parlament übrigens
an mit den Luxemburg leags dann über die
Panama papers und irgend das ist ja auch
eine Welt da geht's nicht immer nur um
die Bekämpfung Finanzskandal gibt's auch
eigene Interessen da gibt's auch
informationshändler und die haben dann
irgendwann wohl gedacht dass ich das
ganz gut öffentlich rüberbringen D sind
auch öfters mal Informationen bei mir
gelandet aber ich bin eigentlich als ich
vor 10 Jahren ins Europäische Parlament
eingezogen bin da war ja so noch die
Ausläufe der Finanz und Eurokrise
ähm kleiner Werbeblock darum wird das
auch auch neben finanzskandalen in
meinem Buch Ken und darüber habe
ich das war eigentlich so mein
politischche Schwerpunkt und ich möchte
ich habe mich ja auch z.B in den letzten
Jahren zur Frage der
Vermögensbesteuerung Impulse gesetzt be
ich war glaube ich der erste monndestag
übergewinnsteuer Mal gefordert hat z
schon in der coronakrise Reform der
Schuldenbremse da bin ich noch angeguckt
worden wie ein pfert haben mir sogar die
Grünen 2019 noch erzählt können wir
nicht machen heute ist das jetzt
Position von Kai Wegner also deswegen
will ich darauf nicht reduzi werden aber
wenn Finanzskandal kommt und das ist ja
leider so sicher wie das Arm in der
Kirche werde ich mich natürlich gerne
drum kümmern aber weil das ja gerade bei
Corona angesprochen war wir haben ja z.B
eine
eu-kmissions Präsidentin die diese
ganzen impstoffverträge bis heute nicht
richtig transparent macht wo ja auch
Milliarden Profit erzielt wurden ich bin
ich bin geimpft ja ich habe mich
entschieden mich impfen zu lassen aber
natürlich wir hatten damals eine
politische Situation in der Debatte da
gab's nur noch also hört hat man jetzt
morgens den Drosten Podcast oder
dann gab es sagen diejenigen die sich
gegen jeglich Maßnahmen geschwert haben
und es muss ja auch noch irgendwie was
dazwischen geben und ich finde da ist
viel kaputt gegangen in der Gesellschaft
und ich krieg das mit weil
das hat ja so ein digitalisierungsschub
gegeben auch im Negativen ne also weiß
ich nicht dass alle bei Amazon oder so
einkaufen aber dann eben auch in den
Schulen und Kinder lernen nicht so dass
ich den einfach ein iPad in die Hand
drücke und dann ist gut und da ist was
kaputt gegangen und da ist natürlich
auch was im Vertrauen in der
Gesellschaft kaputt gegangen wir erleben
das in politischen Debatten jetzt auf
Twitter oder X oder so
weil da so wirklich digitale
Parallelgesellschaften entstanden sind
und ich finde das muss man aufarbeiten
und da muss man auch diejenigen
respektieren die für sich eine andere
Entscheidung getroffen haben und wenn
man dann z.B über impfflicht diskutiert
oder so obwoh es keine sterile Immunität
gibt so also ein Akt der Bestrafung oder
so das finde ich einfach politisch
falsch und da gibt's also genug Themen
auch bei Frau von der lin
wir gehen eine Reihe weiter nach vorne
Herr scholk und sein Nachbar vielleicht
einigen sie sich in welcher Reihenfolge
sie
fragen wür noch mal zur auenol
zurü zu ihrem Friedensplan für die
Ukraine wie sieht
konkret aus nach der russischen
Rechtslage wäre ein Frieden nöglich in
dem Fall wenn bestimmt teil
ihresums
wen sie für so eine Lösung zu
haben also ich finde das erstmal wichtig
ist dass die Waffen schweigen und das
Gespräche beginnen natürlich hat es
wenig Sinn vorab zu sagen und wir hier
entscheiden das ohnehin nicht wie die
Gespräche ausgehen ich habe aber schon
mit Interesse zur Kenntnis genommen dass
der ukrainische Chefunterhändler damals
in istanbur das ist der heutige
Fraktionsvorsitzende der selenski Partei
in kieev also das ist jetzt nicht jemand
der irgendwie tinah ist oder so der hat
ja im letzten Jahr im Herbst letzten
Jahres ein Interview gegeben in einer im
ukrainischen Fernsehen und er hat dort
gesagt dass in Istanbul das waren ja die
ersten Friedensgespräche direkt nach dem
Beginn des Krieges dass dort ein Frieden
möglich gewesen wäre wenn die Ukraine
auf die natomitgliedschaft verzichtet
hätte also wenn Sie das wieder aus ihrer
Verfassung herausgenommen hätte wenn Sie
sich für einen neutralen Status
entschieden hätte dass dann da hätte
Frieden geschaffen werden können und
zwar
offensichtlich ohne dass man im donbas
außer jetzt die separatistengebet die
vorher schon abgetrennt waren mehr oder
weniger ohne dass es weitere
gebietszugeständnisse gegeben hätte die
russischen Truppen hätten sich
offensichtlich auf hinter die Linien des
22 Februar des 24 Februar zurückgezogen
also das ist die Aussage des
ukrainischen Chefin Unterhändlers die
entspricht dem was andere Beteiligte
auch der türkische Außenminister
über diese Gespräche gesagt haben also
es gab offensichtlich damals ein
Zeitfenster ob das heute noch so ist
weiß ich nicht wo die Ukraine ohne
territoriale Zugeständnisse tatsächlich
hätte Frieden schließen können in etwa
so auf dem Level der Minsker des Minsker
Abkommens das wäre damals noch mal
wiederholbar gewesen es gibt ja auch vom
Herbst letzten Jahres ein ein
Friedensvorschlag oder eine Art
Friedensplan von dem ehemaligen
Generalinspekteur der Bundeswehr Harald
Kujat und anderen die sagen man sollte
daran wieder anknüpfen ich weiß nicht ob
es noch mal wirklich eine solche
Möglichkeit der Verständigung gibt weil
eben seitdem der Krieg weitergegangen
ist die besetzten Gebiete von Russland
annektiert wurden das war alles damals
noch nicht aber zumindest zeigt doch
diese diese Geschehnisse zeigen doch
eins dass das Gerede was uns immer
erzählt wurde wir müssen mehr Waffen
liefern damit die Ukraine in eine
bessere Verhandlungsposition kommt dass
das ein leeres Geschwätz war sondern
dass das Gegenteil stattgefunden hat wir
haben viele Waffen geliefert und die
ukrainische Verhandlungsposition hat
sich permanent verschlechtert sie ist
heute eindeutig schlechter als im
Frühjahr
2022 in soweit weiß ich wie gesagt nicht
ich bin auch nicht diejenige die das
entscheidet wie solche Gespräche
ausgehen ich halte es trotzdem für
elementar weil auch viele Kenntnisse
Kenntnis kenntnisreiche Leute und
Experten sagen dass es jetzt eigentlich
wirklich nur noch darum geht verliert
die Ukraine den Krieg oder schafft man
es möglichst schnell Gespräche
einzuleiten deswegen bin ich dafür
schnell einen Waffenstillstand mit
Gesprächen einzuleiten nicht weiterhin
dort jeden Tag hunderte junger Männer
auf dem Schlachtfeld zu opfern für einen
Krieg den die Ukraine und da sind sicher
nun inzwischen auch die generelle der
Ukraine selbst einig den die Ukraine
nicht gewinnen kann also es bringt auch
einfach nichts Vorbedingungen zu setzen
und jetzt zu sagen wir verhandeln erst
wenn alle russischen Truppen sich
komplett zurückziehen sie werden das
nicht tun also muss es jetzt ein Versuch
geben dort wieder Verhandlungen zu
ermöglichen ich hielt es für fatal dass
das so lange nicht gemacht wurde es hat
sich nichts verbessert dadurch aber
jetzt muss man eben alles dafür tun dass
es dazu kommt weil sonst tatsächlich ein
ganz anderes Kriegsende auch möglich
scheint wenn das wenn der Ukraine die
Soldaten ausgehen was ja einige Militär
Militärs durchaus
erwarten was führt sie denn zu der
Annahme oder zu der Überzeugung im Falle
eines ein feuerpuse eines
friedensabschluss Putin dort halten
weitert sein programmiertes Ziel ja ist
der wen
der also viele Experten sagen es geht in
der und das ist auch meine Überzeugung
es geht und in der Ukraine zentral um
die Frage wird die Ukraine ein
Aufmarschgebiet amerikanischer
Militärbasen amerikanischer Raketen das
ist auch das was die russische Seite
immer wieder kommuniziert hat und der
der potenziell mögliche friedenssfluss
von Istanbul bestätigt das also der
hätte ja bedeutet dass die Russen sich
zurückziehen wenn sie dafür die die
Neutralität bekommen und wahrscheinlich
auch die Zusage dass es keine
Raketenbasen und keine weiteren
Militärstützpunkte gibt die gab es ja
vorher schon es gab ja schon 2000
amerikanische Soldaten auf
ukrainischenem Territorium 4000
natosoldaten also inoweit finde ich die
Vorgeschichte Spr nicht für ihre These
und ansonsten muss man doch einfach
sagen es muss geredet werden um zu sehen
was da was was man erreichen kann wenn
man keine Gespräche führt kann man auch
nichts erreichen und es haben sich viele
Länder des Südens seit langem für solche
Gespräche eingesetzt es hat sich der
Papst eingesetzt und es hat sich auch
China eingesetzt wo ja auch ein gewisser
Einfluss auf Russland mal also
vorausgesetzt werden kann also ich halte
es nicht für aussichtslos und zu sagen
das wird doch alles nichts deswegen
versuchen wir es erst gar nicht glaube
ich ist eine Position die die nicht
weiterführt so jetzt geht's ne an
weiter ich habe in den vergangen aller
Stunden ein Thema ziemlich vermisst
Ausführung jetzt kurz angeschnitten
wurde in der coronafrage nämlich das
Gesundheitswesen W Seen mus s
vergangenes Jahr alle Berufsgruppen auf
der Straße gewesen hab protestiert wir
laufen sen Auges in der Versorgungskrise
Herr Lauterbach Versuch grundlegen
kystem
umzubauen und will auch beversorgung
weitermachen da weiß ich gar nichts bei
ih also wie sie aufgestellt haben sie da
Konzepte und Ideen Fall
welche ja kann ich kann ich gerne was zu
sagen sie haben da viele viele Probleme
angesprochen wir haben in der Tat ein
Gesundheitssystem das dazu führt dass
die Versorgung für alle Menschen nicht
gut sichergestellt ist ein
Gesundheitssystem in dem die besch
dasind vor allen Dingen die Pflegerinnen
und Pfleger massiv leiden wir wissen
dass gute Pflege immer schwieriger
überhaupt zu ermöglichen ist in dieser
Situation und das Problem ist entstanden
als im Gesundheitswesen in großem Stile
privatisiert worden ist dass man
Pflegeeinrichtungen Kliniken auf Profit
getrimmt hat hat zu all diesen
Verwerfungen geführt die wir jetzt auch
sehen Herr Lauterbach ist übrigens auch
ja einer der mit Erfinder oder einer der
der geistigen Väter des fallpauschal
Systems was auch diese Situation
verschärft hat eben dass im
Gesundheitsbereich ist nicht mehr danach
geht was ist wirklich notwendig sondern
was es profitabel und was müssen
Kliniken anbieten um überhaupt über die
Runden kommen zu können das sind ja
absurde Situationen dass man z.B in
einigen in dass man z.B dann sagt okay
es müssen jetzt xzahl an Knieoperationen
in einem Jahr stattfinden sonst wird das
überhaupt nicht erstattet das ist ein
Anreiz zu schaffen bestimmte Operationen
durchzuführen und andere Dinge die dann
nicht rentabel sind kann kann man sich
kann man das sich L gar nicht mehr
leisten könnte ich lange drüber sprechen
das war es mit basierend auf dem
Gedankengut von Herrn Lauterbach davon
hat er sich nicht abgekehrt und was er
jetzt in der in der sogenannten Reform
die er auf den Weg gebracht hat versucht
ist oder was er da erreichen wird ist
dass noch mehr Kliniken schließen müssen
und dass die Versorgungslage sich noch
weiter weiter zuspitzt natürlich ist auf
der einen Seite gut zu sagen es ist
Spezialkliniken wo bestimmte Expertise
ist aber man muss natürlich trotzdem
dafür sorgen dass flächendeckend ähm
gute Gesundheitsversorgung da ist das
heißt das ist etwas wofür wir eintreten
wollen wir wollen gute
Gesundheitsversorgung flächendecken im
ganzen Land und da muss man natürlich
gegen den privatisierungskurs etwas tun
der eine große Wurzel ist des Problems
und man muss die Bezahlung der
Krankenhäuser auf eine Art und Weise
umgestalten dass es darum geht Patienten
gut zu versorgen und nicht darum geht
möglichst teure Behandlungen sich
finanzieren zu lassen um das mal ganz
kurz zu fassen ich wollte kurz aus
Europa politischer Sicht ergänzen dass
es ohne jetzt weiteren Namen zu nennen
auch Personen geben wird auf unserer
Liste die genau äh diese
gesundheitspolitische Kompetenz
repräsentieren ähm wir haben uns ja
immer gegen Privatisierung äh des
Gesundheitswesens Fallpauschalen und so
diese Systema ausgesprochen hab wir
werden auch wirklich Praktiker haben das
wird sich also auch auf der Europaliste
äh widerspiegeln und noch eine letzte
Bemerkung ähm auch zu dem äh zu dem
vorhin Gesagten ähm es ist ja so ich
finde es immer absurd dass wir darüber
diskutieren was genau Putin vorhat ohne
dass in Gesprächen auch
herauszufinden und wir haben 2014 ja
eine Situation gehabt wo Putin wenn es
jetzt nur um die imperialen Ambitionen
gegangen wäre die es sicherlich auch
gibt in Russland aber wenn es jetzt nur
darum gegangen wäre völlig frei davon
dass er dann weiß nicht NATO Bündnisfall
oder sonst was auslösen würde jetzt hier
überall einzumarschieren hätte er 2014
in einer sehr viel besseren
militärischen Situation gewesen das zu
tun deswegen finde ich immer falsch man
muss auch sprechen um herauszufinden ob
es ein commitment
gibt gut ähm ich ich habe immer noch
meldung vom Anfang der Pressekonferenz
nur um das noch mal sozusagen zu
kommunizieren wir gehen jetzt eine weit
Reihe weiter nach vorne Herr fürstener
und sein Nachbar dann habe ich hier noch
äh die Kollegin dann habe ich sie noch
auf der Liste dann habe ich sie noch da
hinten auf der Liste entschuldigung das
sollte nicht respektierlich sein und sie
habe ich auch noch und dann habe ich
dann haben wir es glaube ich geschafft
bitte so jetzt V ich höre bei Ihnen aber
auch bei allen anderen raus dass sie
große Sorge den Zusammenhalt der
Gesellschaft haben sich Sorgen um den
Zustand der Demokratie machen V diesem
mittergrund meine Frage da sie ja
verständlicherweise nicht nur sie gerade
auchasi sehr viel Kritik an der
Regierung
kamen und da aber eine Sprache auch
benutzen die selbstpaltend wirken kann
sie sagen die Bundesregierung sei
arrogant und spalteet dit die
Gesellschaft wir fallen da auf gantis KF
warum befleißigen sie sich einer solchen
rotorik wenn sie doch die Sorge haben
dass gerade das auch dazu führt was sie
kritisieren ja wenn
Arroganz auf der politischen Ebene
stattfindet finde ich muss man das auch
benennen also es ist ja also es ist ja
nicht unsere Aufgabe zu beschönigen und
ich finde die Art und Weise wie die
Bundesregierung kommuniziert neben dem
Umstand was sie für Politik macht die
ich auch für ftal halte aber auch die
Art und Weise wie sie mit den Menschen
kommuniziert wie sie über die Köpfe der
we Menschen hinweg
tatsächlich auch S die Themen behandelt
die spiegelt meines Erachtens eine
erhebliche Arroganz wieder also wirklich
ein ein auch ein herangehen was die
Menschen vor den Kopf stößt und
natürlich polarisiert das natürlich
spaltet das auch und wir sind angetreten
um die Dinge beim Namen zu nennen und
nicht
so also politkauderwsch zu reden wo die
Leute am Ende so meine jemand der das
sehr perfekt beherrscht ist eben unser
Bundeskanzler der kann eine Stunde reden
und danach weiß man nicht was er gesagt
hat da ist er hat er vielleicht
niemanden auf die Füße getreten aber ich
glaube nicht dass das die Kommunikation
ist die die Menschen sich wünschen
sondern sie möchten ja schon dass die
Dinge angesprochen werden die sie auch
stören und das wollen wir in einer
sachlichen Art und Weise wir werden
keine Hetze keine keineäh Beschimpfungen
unsachlicher Art praktizieren das ist
schon unser Selbstanspruch aber wir
wollen natürlich schon sehr deutlich und
hart das kritisieren wo wir sagen das
läuft falsch mus ich noch mal nachfragen
Arroganz und Unfähigkeit der Regierung
zustellen ist ja legitim Gehör zum
politischen Geschäft die
Schlussfolgerung darum geht's darau
schlussfolg dass damit die Gesellschaft
das Land gespaltet wird in dieser Logik
wird das Land eigentlich sein gespaltet
WE und Unfähigkeit
politikid ja aber es geht doch auch es
geht do auch den Inhalt von Politik und
ich will mal sagen also wir können das
jetzt mal hier so wissenschaftlich
vertiefen es gibt eine Studie ich habe
die eingangs erwähnt der schwedischen
also waren schwedische Zentralbanker
beteiligt ganz klar ausgewertet in bei
über 200 Wahlen in Europa das z.
Kürzungspolitik die wir jetzt ja mitten
in der Rezession machen ich habe ja die
Zahlen von realöhnen genannt dass das
die politische Rechte stärkt es sind
einfach empirische Ergebnisse und dann
zu sagen das ist alles der Diskurs und
hat irgendwie was mitm Wetter zu tun
oder so und nicht mit der Ampel finde
ich ehrlich gesagt auch ein bisschen
billig da gibt's eine politische
Verantwortung wir sehen ja die AFD war
mal in ihrer gründungsfah so bei 3% und
jetzt stehen die kurz vor der absoluten
Mehrheit in Sachsen zu sagen das hat
nichts mit der herstellen Politik zu tun
ist do völlig Welt und lebensfremd und
da muss ich ehrlich gesagt sagen wenn
wenn wenn sozusagen dann gesagt wird ja
weil die AFD so stark ist darf man die
Ampel nicht mehr kritisieren dann macht
man ja das Geschäft der AFD das ist doch
der Punkt und da muss ich auch sagen da
bin ich es leid diese Diskussion also da
geht's nicht es es reicht eben nicht
dass weiß ich nicht Herr habbig die
Haare schön trägt und ein Video macht
sondern die Leute haben ja am Ende
ihres Monats müssen ihre Miete bezahlen
das ist der entscheidende Punkt und da
sprechen die empirischen Studien ganz
klar dass die Ampel einen Weg geht das
haben wir ja auch schon wähend der
Eurokrise in anderen europäischen
Ländern gesehen der die der die AFD
stark machen wird das ist übrigens der
entscheidende Punkt warum ich wieder in
die Politik gegangen bin weil ich dieser
Entwicklung nicht zusehen möchte der
Generalsekretär hat das Wort danke schön
ja das war die Pressekonferenz zur
Gründung der Partei Bündnis Sarah
Wagenknecht kurz BSW nach etwa einer
Stunde und 45 Minuten gehen wir jetzt
mal aus der Pressekonferenz raus hallo
noch mal willkommen zu ZDF heute live
schön dass ihr noch bei uns seid oder
neu dazuekommen ja also welche Chancen
hat diese wagenknechtpartei darüber
wollen wir jetzt sprechen gleich mit dem
Politikwissenschaftler Professor
Thorsten FS von der Freien Universität
Berlin er sieht in den Plänen von Sarah
Wagenknecht vor allem auch einen Trend
zur Personalisierung von Politik in
Deutschland schickt uns eure Fragen uns
interessieren auch eure Kommentare die
postet ihr am besten in die Chats oder
ihr schickt uns eine E-Mail wir starten
jetzt mit unserer
hauptstadtkorrespondentin Andrea
Maurer
hallo
Andrea hallo Jessica also du warst bis
eben auch in der Bundespressekonferenz
hast alles verfolgt Sarah Wagenknecht
hat heute Vormittag von einem
historischen Moment gesprochen war das
jetzt in dieser Pressekonferenz spürbar
für
dich also es war auf jeden Fall heute
spürbar dass diese Partei sich sozusagen
als historisch empfindet wir waren ja
heute morgen schon dabei da haben sich
Sarah Wagenknecht und 44
Gründungsmitglieder hier in einem Hotel
in Berlin getroffen die Wahlen haben
stattgefunden also sie als
Parteivorsitzende gewählt Amira Mohammed
Ali als Parteivorsitzende der
Generalsekretär Christian lei der
Bundesgeschäftsführer da wurde also
sozusagen das Personal bestimmt und das
war schon eine sehr gelöste Atmosphäre
in der man sich da getroffen hat und
im Grunde genommen ist das jetzt der
Jahresauftakt natürlich für ein Wahljahr
wo vier Wahlen anstehen die Europawahl
drei Landtagswahlen im Osten und wo sich
dieses Bündnis sarer Wagenknecht eben
viel erhofft und wo sie eben hofft auch
eine Stimmungslage der Bevölkerung eben
aufzugreifen und an den wahluhren da
eben viele Stimmen einsammeln zu können
jetzt hat ja Sarah Wagenknecht eben
nicht mit Kritik gespart an der
Regierung an den bestehenden
Verhältnissen wenn ich jetzt in den Chat
schaue da wird so ein bisschen
kritisiert dass es auf der anderen Seite
aber wenig Konstrukt es gab also Fluffi
schreibt auf Youtube bisher höre ich nur
Möglichkeiten Beschwerden aber eben
keinerlei Lösungen okay 123 schreibt was
sind denn die Lösungen die Probleme sind
ja schon lange bekannt hätte man da mehr
erwarten
können also es ist schon
deutlich gewesen auch die Beobachtung
die der Nutzer da geteilt hat also es
war schon eine sozusagen
antiampelstimmung eine
antiregierungsstimmung die hier
aufgegriffen wurde die ist ja aktuell im
Land gibt wir haben ja heute hier in
Berlin auch die bauernproteste wo sich
Sarah Wagenknecht ja auch deutlich an
die Seite der Bauern stellt und da eben
den Finger in die Wunde legt also ein
generelles Gefühl der Unzufriedenheit
mit dieser Regierung mit den
Haushaltskürzungen oder mit dem schlecht
gemachten Haushalt der jetzt eben
Kürzungen in vielen Bereichen bedeutet
und da versucht sich schon eine Stimmung
denke ich zu bedienen und ja diese
Partei möchte sich ein Programm geben
das haben wir ja auch hier gehört hört
sie hat es aber eben noch nicht richtig
festgeschrieben sondern sie haben ja
gesagt Sie wollen das gemeinsam noch
entwickeln das heißt sozusagen das
konstruktive also den den wirklichen
Plan da hat man natürlich teilweise
schon Programmatik rausgehört aber das
ist eben noch nicht
noch nicht in Stein gemeißelt sozusagen
und da will sie sich ja auch noch bei
dem Parteitag am 27 Januar wollen sie
sich auch ein europawahlprogramm geben
also das dürfen wir dann auch mit
Spannung erwarten welche
Lösungsvorschläge eigentlich sag
Wagenknecht und ihre Leute dann
tatsächlich haben und wie sie sozusagen
mehr sein wollen als kritische
Opposition dennoch haben wir ja ein
bisschen mehr über die Partei erfahren
wo würdest du sie einordnen links rechts
Mitte Sarah Wagenknecht wollte sich ja
nicht so richtig in diese Schubladen
einordnen
lassen ja deutlich war hier dass sich
eigentlich die meisten in dieser
Bundespressekonferenz von dem
sogenannten Label Links eigentlich
verabschiedet haben sie haben alle
gesagt das was sie mal unter Links
verstanden haben ist im Grunde genommen
anders belegt also sie verbinden heute
links mit Identitätspolitik mit
genderdebatte und da haben sie sich eben
von distanziert und sarer Wagenknecht
hat ja gesagt du hast es auch gesagt ein
neues Label der Zuordnung muss gefunden
werden ich würde sagen die
repräsentationslücke die Sie aktuell in
Deutschland für sich sieht ist
so links konservativ das wurde ja auch
vielfah von der Wissenschaft schon so
beschrieben also im Grunde genommen hat
sie einen sozial es ein
sozialkonservatives Programm mit einem
migrationskritischen Ansatz und da mit
einem sozusagen deutlichen
friedensansatz das ist vielleicht auch
noch eine linke Programmatik die da
reinspielt die konservative Programmatik
ist eben eindeutig denke ich in der
Migrationsfrage zu finden ganz
interessanter Punkt war ja eben dass die
Partei bei der Europawahl antreten will
und bei den drei anstehenden
Landtagswahlen in Sachsen Brandenburg
und
Thüringen das ist reltiv ambitioniert
oder so organisatorisch ist das ist das
zu stemmen ist das
realistisch ja also es ist total
ambitioniert in Wahrheit haben wir heute
auch nur erfahren dass es sicher ist
dass sie zur Europawahl antreten und
dass sie anstreben zu den drei
Landtagswahlen im Osten anzutreten es
ist dann auch noch mal ambitionierter
das hat ja Sarah Wagenknecht gesagt wenn
man eben bedenkt dass sie beispielsweise
in Thüringen die Möglichkeit sogar einer
Regierungsbeteiligung hätten wenn man
aktuellen Umfragen gerade folgt und das
heißt da braucht sie einfach Personal
was
regierungsfähig wäre was politisch
beschlagen ist und da sich diese Partei
noch im Aufbau befindet und ja auch die
Personalsuche noch gar nicht
abgeschlossen ist also die Leute mit
denen Sie jetzt hier heute saß das ist
natürlich die Parteispitze und trotzdem
braucht sie natürlich auch in der Fläche
gute Kandidatinnen und Kandidaten und so
war Sarah wagenkncht zu verstehen sie
ist zuversichtlich aber entschieden ist
das eben noch noch nicht letzte Frage an
dich Andrea wie groß ist jetzt die
Aufregung in der Hauptstadt äh macht es
die anderen Parteien nervös dass sich
diese Partei bündnissarer Wagenknecht
jetzt gegründet hat und quasi ihren Hut
in den Ring
schmeißt ja also ich denke es ist eine
Parteigründung die natürlich auch von
den ähm anderen Parteien ausgewertet
wird wir hören auch immer wieder dass
beispielsweise Wahlforscher
Meinungsforscher ähm zu den Parteien
inkommen also beispielsweise bei der CDU
und eben auswerten wo das Potenzial
dieser wagenknechtpartei liegt und wo es
Schnittmengen wo es Abgrenzungen gibt m
ich glaube was im Grunde genommen die
Nervosität hier noch steigert ist dass
ja eben wie gesagt die allgemeine
Stimmungslage gerade so gestresst und
verunsichert ist und das sehen wir ja
eben auch noch mal an den
bauernprotesten heute dass es eben auch
in diesem Jahr auch an den wahlohren
eben eine Dynamik geben könnte die ähm
die da nicht absehbar ist also das ist
eben gerade für die etablierten Parteien
und wir haben ja auch die Wahlumfragen
die aktuellen in Sachsen wo die SPD bei
3% liegt was natürlich ein desaströser
Wert für eine Kanzlerpartei ist
dass das eben natürlich für Unruhe sorgt
dass es offenbar großes Potenzial bei
anderen Parteien ja auch bei der AFD bei
der bei dem bündnisarer wagenkncht gibt
vielen Dank Andrea Maurer nach
Berlin mach's gut tschüss
ja und da wollen wir direkt Weitergehen
zu Professor Thorsten FAS von der Freien
Universität in Berlin hallo Herr FS
grüße sie hallo ich grüße Sie Herr F
wenn ich schaue wie die Stimmung so im
Chat ist da heißt es z. be Tommy
schreibt
das wird die bessere SPD BSW oder Loa
schreibt das sei eine sehr wichtige und
notwendige Alternative
wie würden Sie das einschätzen wo steckt
da das Potential drin für dieses Bündnis
die politische Landschaft in Deutschland
mal ordentlich
aufzumischen na wir haben das beim Blick
in die Geschichte ja durchaus schon
öfter erlebt wenn man sich überlegt wie
die Grünen entstanden sind wie die
Linkspartei auch entstanden ist dann
sind es eben durchaus Projekte auf der
linken Seite des politischen Spektrums
gewesen die aber eben aus einer
Unzufriedenheit mit einer bestehenden
Regierung heraus entstanden sind
insofern zeigt diese blickt durchaus
dass es erfolgreich sein kann auf der
anderen Seite muss man sagen ist der
Platz im Parteienspektrum natürlich
inzwischen schon sehr sehr gut gefüllt
und auch das haben wir heute gehört man
will sehr vorsichtig vorgehen man will
eben nicht eine Sammelstelle für alle
möglichen neu Mitglieder werden sondern
sehr langsam wachsen sehr vorsichtig
wachsen um eben nicht Gefahr zu laufen
in eine Situation zu kommen wie das bei
neuen Parteien häufig der Fall ist dass
sie zu schnell wachsen zu
unterschiedliche Positionen in sich
vereinen also diesen schmalen Grad da
ist eine Chance und die will man nutzen
ohne zu überreizen den zu finden da weiß
man glaube ich genau wie schwierig die
Situation ist aber genau diesen Grad
will man finden mhm werden wir ganz
konkret es ist ja immer wieder die Rede
davon dass die
wagenknechtspartei eine Alternative zur
Alternative für Deutschland sprich AFD
werden könnte davon spricht Sara
Wagenknecht ja auch selbst ähm da gibt's
zu gibt's eine Frage von fabi wie gut
stehen den wagenknechtschancen mit ihrer
Partei der CDU und aber eben
insbesondere auch der AFD Wähler zu
klauen na allein an der Frage merkt man
schon dass die Konstellation die wir
heute im Parteienspektrum haben eben
nicht mehr einfach links versus rechts
ist sondern dass es da um ökonomische
wirtschaftliche Fragen geht vielleicht
auch Fragen des Sozialstaates die man
typischerweise so mit Links versus
rechts bezeichnet hätte aber wir haben
es ja auch von Sarah Wagenknecht heute
gehört dass wir auch viel über
kulturelle fragen frag
identitätspolitische Fragen auch
außenpolitische fragen fragen von Krieg
und Frieden sprechen und das dort gar
nicht mehr so einfach ist links und
rechts klar zuzuordnen und hinzu kommt
natürlich Stichwort AFD dass wir einfach
eine sehr sehr große Unzufriedenheit mit
der ampelregierung haben und das ist
wenn man so will die Gefahr die für die
AFD besteht hier ist das hat man heute
sehr sehr deutlich gemerkt eine weitere
politische Kraft mit einer sehr
prominenten Person an der Spitze die
genau diese unzufrieden in ihre Bahnen
lenken möchte die sich als Alternative
zu dieser Regierung präsentieren möchte
das gelingt der AFD bisher sehr gut aber
da bekommt jetzt starke Konkurrenz
insofern ist es auch für die AFD
sicherlich eine neue Konkurrenz bei der
CDU wä ich so ein wenig vorsichtiger
klar auch die CDU ist Opposition und wir
sehen hier einfach dass die Opposition
größer wird aber die Schnittmengen dort
schein mir inhaltlich doch kleiner zu
sein und auch von der Art wie hier
Protest formuliert wird wird und wie man
versucht unzufrieden in die eigene
Richtung zu lenken ist es doch ein etwas
anderes Modell mm bleiben wir noch mal
kurz bei der AFD also die
Migrationspolitik dieser neuen Partei
bündnissarer wagenknechts haben wir
jetzt schon gehört die ist ja wesentlich
gemäßigter und so ganz klar sind die
Positionen ja auch noch nicht warum
sollte das für AFD wälerin und Weller
dennoch attraktiv sein beim nächsten Mal
das Kreuz bei beim BSW zu machen ja das
ist ein wichtiger Punkt weil er eben
auch zeigt dass die Gründe für eine AFD
war sehr verschieden sein können es gibt
sicherlich Personen und das sind nicht
wenige inzwischen die die AFD wegen
ihrer Position wählen gerade eben auch
wegen ihrer migrationskritischen
Positionen und da hat BSW da hat Sarah
Wagenknecht und das Team das wir gerade
gesehen haben durchaus versucht
sozusagen Skepsis Kritik am bestehen
bestehenden migrations System zu äußern
aber weitaus moderater als wir das von
Seiten der AFD hören also glaube es geht
nicht darum diese wirklichen
migrationsgegner in die eigene Richtung
zu lenken sondern wirklich eher diesen
zweiten Pool dieses zweite Reservoir von
Wählerinnen und Wählern die bisher vor
allem bei der AFD landen nämlich die aus
einer großen Unzufriedenheit einer Wut
heraus auch gegen die Regierung AFD
wählen und die will man jetzt in
Richtung BSW in Richtung bündnisar Wagen
nicht lenken also es gibt eben nie nur
den einen Grund warum wählerinen und
Wähler eine bestimmte Partei wählen und
gerade dieser dieses Reservoir von
unzufriedenen um die wird BSW kämpfen
und dort auch sehr klar sich gegen die
AFD positionieren und sagen wir sind an
der Stelle eigentlich die bessere die
linkere wenn man so will auch
alternative mit einem moderat
migrations ja skeptischen Kurs würde ich
sagen man hat da sehr viel über das
individual recht äh gesprochen aber das
war eine sehr komplexe Argumentation die
wir da gehört haben mm AFD Chef kupala
hat ja gesagt er hat keine Angst vor
dieser neuen Partei ich meine klar was
soll er auch anderes sagen ähm aber
genau beobachten wird man die
Entwicklung doch
schon ja absolut die die spannende Frage
ist wir wir wissen ja aus Umfragen dass
es durchaus ein Reservoir ein Potenzial
gibt für Wählerin und Wähler dieser
neuen Partei die sich heute gegründet
hat und die spannende Frage ist nimmt es
den etablierten den sogenannten
etablierten Parteien Wählerinnen und
Wähler weg oder sehen wir tatsächlich
dass sich
dort wo sich der Protest sammelt also
bei AFD vor allem dass sich dort die
Stimmen jetzt anders verteilen werden
insofern klar sie haben es gerade
angedeutet natürlich kann der AFD Chef
nicht sagen dass ihm jetzt angst und
bange ist aber ich glaube man weiß dort
auch schon sehr sehr genau und auch das
zeigen ja Umfragen dass man neue
Konkurrenz bekommen hat das ist für die
AFD eigentlich eine neue Situation denn
in dieser protestrolle war man in den
vergangenen Monaten doch eigentlich
konkurrenzlos die Zeit ist jetzt vorbei
lassen uns übers Geld reden 1,4
Millionen hat die Partei nach eigenen
Angaben
eingesammelt wie ist das einzuordnen für
das was jetzt gerade in der
Pressekonferenz bekannt wurde was Sie
vorhaben ist es ordentlich ist es
wenig na das ist erstmal bemerkenswert
durchaus das zeigt auch dass es dann
gewisse Bereitschaft in verschiedenen
Kreisen gibt dieses Projekt zu
unterstützen zugleich haben wir ja von
Sarah Wagenknecht auch an verschiedenen
Stellen gehört dass sie geradezu um
Förderer und Unterstützer
UnterstützerInnen geworben hat die
selbst wenn Sie kein Mitglied werden
dürfen sofort doch zumindest schon Geld
spenden dürfen also das Geld scheint
auch nach eigener Wahrnehmung der
führenden Köpfe jetzt nicht ausreichend
zu sein und das ist es auch nicht ein
Wahlkampf ist teuer der geht eben was
die Kosten betrifft sehr sehr schnell in
die Millionen insofern 1,4 Millionen das
klingt viel das ist auch für eine neue
Partei oder es war ja eigentlich noch
ein Verein im ersten Schritt durchaus
eine ganze Menge aber wird sicherlich
niemals reichen um das Projekt
nachhaltig zu tragen also da muss
sicherlich noch ein wenig mehr kommen
zumal bisher ja auch keine staatliche
Parteien Finanzierung greifen kann das
Projekt ist ja heute erst zu einer
Partei
geworden ich habe im Chat gesehen dass
ich so ein demasi Fanclub bei uns
gegründet
also da hieß es z. ist einer der besten
Politiker in Deutschland danke SAR dass
du ihn wieder in unsere Politik
zurückbringst jetzt heißt das Bündnis ja
Sarah
Wagenknecht ist das gewollt dass auch
andere neben Sarah Wagenknecht eventuell
so so stark
bestehen na ich habe eben so halb im
Scherz mal kurz getwittert ob man es
nicht besser Bündnis Fabio demasi nennen
sollte denn er war sicher sehr prä in
dieser Pressekonferenz die wir da gerade
erlebt haben auch rhtorisch natürlich
sehr versiert sehr präsent auf der Bühne
und einer der Spitzenkandidaten für die
Europawahl denn das zeigt ja auch das
Dilemma was vor der vor dem Bündnis Sara
Wagen nicht jetzt liegt sie kann nicht
in allen vier Wahlen die möglicherweise
vor der Partei liegen persönlich
antreten das heißt der Name alleine kann
zwar auf dem Wahlzettel stehen aber sie
kann nicht als Spitzenkandidatin in all
diese Wahlen reingehen also so braucht
es mehr Personen und mit den beiden die
wir gesehen haben Fabio deasi aber
natürlich auch Thomas Geisel das sind
respektable
Persönlichkeiten letzteres Thomas geiel
tut der SPD natürlich auch weh weil man
hier immerhin ein frühren
Oberbürgermeister auch abgeworben hat
also das zeigt schon einen gewissen Reiz
strahlt dieses Bündnis aus und die Masi
hier noch mal sicher eine sehr sehr
sichtbare und Präsente Figur das hat man
eben glaube ich sehr schnell gemerkt und
der Fanclub in ihrem Chat der zeigt das
ja auch und dennoch ist es ja so also
ich meine wenn man eine Partei Bündnis
Sarah Wagenknecht nennt dann hat das ja
auch schon ein bisschen was von
Personenkult und sie sagen ja auch das
ist eine ganz interessante Entwicklung
welche Chancen stecken da drin und
welche Risiken aber
auch ja das war sehr sehr spannend was
wir an der Stelle heute gehört haben
Sarah Wagen nicht selber hat ja
geschildert dass es schwierig ist eine
neue Partei zu gründen dass es dafür
natürlich auch auch Bekanntheit braucht
und Sichtbarkeit auch Sichtbarkeit auf
den Stimmzetteln nicht zuletzt und dass
man deswegen erstmal Ihren Namen Ihre
Bekanntheit nutzen will um in diese
Startphase gehen zu können und sehe ich
in der Tat so das ist ein Novum dass wir
hier erleben dass sich eine Partei auch
ausweißlich ihres Namens tatsächlich
rund um eine Person gründet das hatten
wir so eigentlich nicht aber interessant
war auch dass sie gesagt hat das gilt
erstmal bis zur Bundes tagswahl
2025 und danach wolle man neu überlegen
wie die Partei dann eigentlich heißen
soll also hier soll es vor allem darum
gehen die Startphase zu erleichtern eben
die Bekanntheit von Sarah Wagenknecht
bei aller bei allem was die Masi heute
dort sozusagen gezeigt hat ist er bei
weitem nicht so bekannt wie Sarah
Wagenknecht es ist also klar der Versuch
hier ihre Bekanntheit zu nutzen um das
Projekt insgesamt zum Laufen zu bringen
dann aber mit Blick auf Nachhalt keit
und verstätigung sich auch klar zumachen
dass sie alleine das nicht wird in die
Zukunft tragen können also da will man
dann das Schicksal der Partei doch ein
wenig Lösen vom Schicksal einer einzigen
Person das ist schon eine ganz Schlaue
Strategie die man sich da überlegt hat
wir haben im Chat hier auch noch eine
Diskussion über die russlandnähe von
Sarah Wagenknecht mit der sie immer
wieder in Verbindung gebracht wird da
gibt's verschiedene Kommentare z.B
schreibt Nanuk ihre Politik würde der UN
den Untergang der der Ukraine bedeuten
oder ein anderer Kommentar eine Partei
die sich für den Frieden einsetzt viel
verlogener geht das ja schon kaum mehr
so wie hier in Russlands Aggression
systematisch beschönigt wird und dann
gibt's auch noch eine Frage die Partei
möchte einen Stopp von Waffenlieferung
in Kriegsgebiete an sich hört das sich
ja gut an aber wie will die neue Partei
das
Durchsetzen ja ich glaube da muss man
ehrlicherweise sagen es geht um den
ersten Teil es hört sich gut an und
richtig ist natürlich wenn auf das
Parteiensystem schaut dann gibt es keine
politische Kraft die die Unterstützung
der Ukraine abschwächen will oder
relativieren will sondern da ist was die
sogenannten etablierten Parteien
betrifft doch eigentlich großer Konsens
zugleich sehen wir in Umfragen dass
viele Menschen auf diesen Krieg mit
durchaus Sorge schauen dass sie sich
einen Frieden wünschen insofern ist eine
Positionierung die hier sagt wir wollen
Frieden und wir sind da auch ganz anders
als die anderen Parteien erstmal
strategisch durchaus eine gute
Aufstellung wie das am Ende
funktionieren soll das muss klingt jetzt
etwas zynisch aber das muss die Partei
heute ja nicht unbedingt interessieren
in der Verantwortung steht sie ja nun
mal nicht ne wir haben ja auch viel
gehört hier Frieden war möglich das hat
man versäumt aber das muss man eben
weiter versuchen ehrlicherweise wird
niemand gegen eine solche Position
Positionierung etwas sagen aber in der
Akzentuierung in dem was man
herausstellt als die eigene Politik
klingt es eben doch anders als das was
wir von anderer Seite hören und das kann
sicherlich noch mal dazu beitragen dass
die Partei den ein oder anderen Bürger
Bürgerin in ihre Richtung ziehen kann mm
Tommy gan schreibt auf Youtube die
wagenknechtpartei wird die SPD halbieren
und auch der AFD viele Wähler wegnehmen
und wenn jetzt noch die werteunion sich
von der CDU abspaltet und eine Partei
gründet dann sind die Volksparteien tot
also dazu muss man sagen hans- Georg
Maßen der frühere Verfasser schutzchef
und eben gleichzeitig auch Vorsitzender
der werteunion hat auch angekündigt dass
er eine neue Partei gründen wird da muss
man dann mal abwarten was daraus wird
aber wo sehen sie das Risiko wie groß
sehen Sie das das was Tommy schreibt
dass die Volksparteien in Gefahr
sind na richtig ist natürlich dass wenn
man sich den das in längerer Sicht
anschaut dass die kombinierten Anteile
von Union und SPD im Zeitverlauf
deutlich deutlich zurückgegangen sind
und wir bei der Bundestagswahl 2021
erstmal eine Situation hatten erstmals
Situation hatten dass der Anteil unter
50% lag standand heute wäre der Anteil
noch geringer ausweißlich von Umfragen
also da ist ohne Zweifel mehr Dynamik im
Parteienwettbewerb drin auf der anderen
Seite muss man auch sagen sind Partei
Neugründungen erfolgreiche Partei
Neugründung doch vergleichsweise selten
wenn wir uns das anschauen dann sind die
Grünen entstanden die linke und die AFD
aber das war es eigentlich auch in der
jüngen Vergangenheit es ist jetzt nicht
so dass permanent neue Parteien sich
problemlos etablieren können und auch
das haben wir in der Pressekonferenz ja
hören können was das für
organisatorische Herausforderung sind
wie groß der Wettbewerb damit natürlich
auch wird denken wir an die Piraten
beispielsweise über die haben wir vor 10
Jahren mal kurzzeitig geredet die sind
dann eigentlich recht geräuschlos wieder
verschwunden also da ist eine Chance da
ich will das gar nicht klar reden aber
das ist alles andere als ein
Automatismus und Dynamik heißt natürlich
auch ja das schafft Chancen für neue
Parteien aber es heißt natürlich auch
dass diese kleinen Parteien sehr schnell
auch in schwieriges terrin in
schwieriges Fahrwasser kommen können
also da wäre ich insgesamt ein bisschen
vorsichtiger vieles in Bewegung aber das
ist nicht unbedingt immer automatisch in
eine Richtung nur sozusagen laufen
sondern das kann sich mal nach oben mal
nach unten bewegen das heißt verstehe
ich sie richtig dass sie die Situation
jetzt erstmal entspannt beobachten denn
es heißt ja oft dass dass viele kleine
Parteien in der Parteienlandschaft eben
m auch eine Gefahr darstellen
können zumindest macht es
regierungsbildungsprozesse schwieriger
das ist völlig unbestritten nur muss man
eben sehen die Situation ist nicht so
dass wir 10 15 Parteien im Parlament
haben sondern wir reden jetzt darüber
dass noch eine weitere Partei vielleicht
dazu kommt ob das be kommen wird oder
nicht wissen wir gar nicht
ehrlicherweise aber ich will nur darauf
hinweisen dass wir manchmal auch mit
Blick auf die AFD Debatten so führen als
könne es für die AFD automatisch nur
nach oben gehen das hat es in der
jüngeren Vergangenheit auch getan ja
aber auch für die AFD haben wir schon
Hochphasen aber auch Rückgänge
Tiefpunkte erlebt und warum sollte es
nicht auch bei diesem neuen Bündnis der
Fall sein der echte Test ob es gelingt
diese dieses Momentum was wir da gerade
se gesehen haben auf die Straße zu
bringen das wird die Zukunft das werden
konkrete Wahlen zeigen die Faszination
ist groß das hat ja auch die
Pressekonferenz mit den vielen vielen
Fragen gezeigt aber oft ist der der
wirkliche Beweis dass es läuft ja dann
wirklich die die harte tägliche
kernearbeit und das wird man dann
tatsächlich sehen wie gut das der Partei
gelingen
wird also dann stellen wir die letzte
Frage die kommt auch aus dem Chat hier
heißt es Frage an den Professor wird mit
Sarah das Bürgergeld erhöht
ja auch da haben wir interessante
Nuancen gehört Thomas geiler hat gesagt
er lehnt ein bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen stckt ab wir haben auch
was gehört äm Bürgergeld mit Blick auf ä
Ukraine Menschen aus der Ukraine die bei
uns sind da waren durchaus auch
zögerliche Worte dabei ähm ich wäre da
vorsichtig wir haben insgesamt wenig
Konkretes gehört gerade wir haben so
Verweise auf entstehende Programme
gehört aber was das am Ende ganz genau
bedeutet dass blieb eigentlich heute
offen gehört haben wir man will sehr
vernünftig sein viel Sachverstand viel
Pragmatismus
äh und man will sozusagen auch den
Protest dem wieder eine andere
Alternative als die AFD geben aber was
das im Detail in einzelnen
Politikfeldern bedeuten wird äh die
Antwort ist das BSW heute noch schuldig
geblieben das ist aber ehrlicherweise
auch okay für eine neue Partei dass die
nicht sofort sozusagen auf alle Fragen
antworten hat trotzdem darf man gespannt
sein wie die dann ausfallen werden
absolut es ist ein Prozess vielen Dank
Professor FS für ihre Einschätzung und
Analyse zur Gründung der Partei Bündnis
Sarah Wagenknecht machen sie es gut
vielen Dank tschüss sehr gerne
tschüss ja und damit möchte ich mich
auch bei euch bedanken für eure Fragen
und Kommentare ZDF heute live bis bald
macht's gut
tschüss